I'll just kicked in.
Yeah.
Here we go.
We're live ladies.
Gentlemen.
Joe Rogan experience podcast.
That's why new opening.
Yeah.
Not just,
I'm just,
I'm going indeed
just Justin base behind it.
We have two sponsors right now,
ladies,
gentlemen and the sponsors are,
are,
are people that get behind us and financially support the show and,
and,
and then they become our friends.
So they are our sponsors but they are also our friends.
Um,
that's how we like to do business here over at the Joe Rogan experience podcast,
like friends with were sponsors.
This is a lot of noise going on about these things suck by the way.
I know they suck because no one uses them,
but us,
Adam Carolla has those like straight pipe things that never move,
which is the way to do it.
That Mike Arms.
Yeah,
they make it screeching noises like a horror movie.
I think it absolutely and kind of like it.
Oh,
you like it.
Okay.
The blog that is arguable.
This park has it brought to your voice squeaking?
Well,
it lets people know that this,
you know,
people will worried that as we move into this new studio,
we're just robots now on the big we're going to,
it's going to clean up too much and it's not going to,
you know what?
I think what they like about this podcast is it's,
it's really obviously like a bunch of guys just sitting around shooting the
shit.
No,
we better we could spoke about while we're doing it.
Yeah.
Instead of having to like not well we could always do it while we're doing it.
As long as we don't do the video.
Did the real issue is the Ustream doesn't like to see that.
Even if it's legal for us,
even if we are technically legally do doing it in the state.
Oh I thought you were just worried about your kids coming by or something.
No,
no one.
I don't just don't do it in the house and doing the house at all.
I don't want my house smelling like weed.
You know what I mean?
Mine through layers like your car.
Did you ever have a car that you smoked weed in and the thing just starts
tanking?
Yeah,
that's not good.
Anyway,
this podcast brought to you by the fleshlight fleshlight.
This is the number one sex toy for men.
The only one that I know of by name.
How about that?
It's like the Kleenex of sex toys.
The rabbit.
That's the only other one.
That's girl one.
Dude,
don't use that.
Okay.
Um,
if you go to Joe rogan.net,
the liquid,
that was your reaction.
I fall down.
Disappointed father.
I turned out to be gay.
All of that to say is don't try to fuck me and everything will be exactly the
same.
That's all I have to say.
It's a no deal stuff yet is crazy.
I can't control my bonus.
Go
ask it.
A gay guy to control his bone.
It's like asking a fucking straight guy to bodyguard girlfriend.
I mean if a girl or you thought was attractive,
said,
don't try to fuck me good to me.
They'd be like og,
definitely to try to fuck you.
Goddamn elephants in the room.
I just said,
how long is my trap?
Is it three years?
How wide is my net?
How slowly do you have to work your way in until she becomes the next message?
Should fear you will get her.
You will pull her in the rear.
We got tired of waiting for girls that can just fuck me already.
Wow.
No,
I don't talk like that.
That's ridiculous.
This sounds a super selfish.
It doesn't seem like it would just like enough is enough.
Silently masturbated alone in the corner where the girl like looked out of the
corner of her eye.
You done.
Are you done?
I've been that guy.
He like,
I gotta I can't take anymore shit ever for a man.
You realize what you're doing and like,
oh my God,
he watches you.
And then once it's over it's over.
You feel like Saatchi Lou has such an insane loser.
Do you get a silence?
I shouldn't say I've only masturbated once with a girl in the same room and then
she masturbated ofso that's okay.
And then I just come down her ted talk.
It was kind of weird.
It was the only time I ever did it.
You know,
like we're both sitting there masturbating for some reason people are fucking
weird.
This is weird.
Just the fact that you were like magnetically attracted to other people.
We were like magnetically hormonally attracted to other other people and you
just try to navigate your way through that wave of humans and you know,
choosing very specifically which ones you interact with.
I mean,
you know what I'm saying?
it's a strange thing when you really break it down and look at it objectively,
how weird the interaction is between human beings,
magnetic charge.
They're just like,
ah,
it's just intuit.
So bizarre man.
You know,
and look at how many of our friends have had like,
you know,
really bad ones.
You know,
Brian,
you've gone through a few fucking chaotic ones.
Well it's like all of a sudden you're dealing with all this craziness in your
life and most of it has started to happening with your physical interaction with
this person.
Like this person you,
you get into their world.
And if you don't look it in terms of the context of our culture and our language
and you know,
and then the shit we're used to seeing on the TV screen,
look at it as just like energy.
That energy is a weird thing,
man.
The men and the women coming together like getting close to each other,
but trying to control the situation.
So don't break up.
Oh my God.
Getting bought,
breaking up,
getting back together and breaking up again and it,
fuck it.
Wasn't that,
that brutal cycle.
Have you ever thrown out like Shale Mary?
I love you.
Like right at the end.
Fuck it.
I'll just brush.
I've thrown out a hail Mary.
Hail Mary.
I love you letters that we got for the shots right now.
Oh yeah.
I wish I had the letter.
It was so humiliating.
I swear I would have read it.
I was even saying to her that we should make babies.
It was so weird.
It was the Wiki shit cause she wouldn't have,
she was done with me,
man.
I went to visit her at work and I forget what we were talking about,
but uh,
she,
she goes,
was your nose always that crooked?
I was like,
Oh shit,
this bitch,
this bitch is not only,
she's like picking me apart.
Now you're hurting me.
Yeah.
Not only is she over me,
she's like breaking that.
Did you get shorter?
You know,
like,
she's like,
oh,
almost want to say
fucking lit.
It's weird ones.
It takes a while to now have some stranger said.
The second thing you'd be like,
no,
I don't know what forget.
It takes a while to navigate relationships,
man.
Especially when you don't have your shit together.
You know,
when I was a young man,
I,
who the fuck would have wanted to date me?
I wouldn't have wanted a date in May.
I was an idiot.
If someone said something to me recently,
yesterday,
my sister,
it goes and I sort of want an ugly choke because I want her to feel lucky to be
happening.
Ultimately,
trust me,
women who have power complexes,
they always get a Beta man.
They get a man who's below them on the food chain and then they control that
motherfucker on a leash.
We've all seen that guy who has to like pretend to be someone different and keep
his mouth shut and he's and his girl way too hot for him.
Hey,
stop talking about me.
I'm right here.
These,
how about these guys?
And I don't want to be mean,
so I'm trying to figure out how to say this that have wives that do porn and
they,
they sort of just sit back.
They're kind of cool with it.
That's just what she does.
Yeah,
I think it adds much.
Just shut off.
It'd be like that.
It's something that is a crazy thought process right there.
This is still the commercials.
That's fucking hustle brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com it's o.
N.
I.
T.
A lot of this porn talk goes a lot with flashlight as well though.
Downplays the codename Rogan,
say 15% off on the flashlight and use a codename rogue and save 10% off any and
all orders on,
on at.com what's up on it when you get to catch up on it?
What's good?
15% oh yeah.
I know that we need to get them that it should be 15% right?
Just raise it $5,
raise it $5.
They're not the choice.
That price and then charge more percent.
That's rude.
No,
it's easy.
You know,
um,
I'm thinking into the mic.
I've been getting in way too many fucking arguments on the Internet a couple
days.
I just fielding Douchebag,
fight back.
There's so many do.
That's just a screaming and I,
you know,
I know,
but every now and then I can't help,
but I can't help it.
There's a,
there was people keep wanting.
Here's one of the issues is Alpha Brain Alpha brain is this cognitive enhancing
supplement that we sell and for whatever fucking reason people like to cry.
Bullshit.
They'd love it.
They love,
I'm saying you're bullshitting and love saying it's a placebo.
They love saying vitamins that enhance neuro function,
they enhanced your brain's ability to produce neurotransmitters as or as how
it's been explained to me.
I'm going to be able to accept that I know none of this,
but I do know that there's all those tests that had been done and all the
different ingredients and you know,
it's all up on,
there's like there's an Alpha brain science link on,
on at
Dotcom and explains all this shit.
The impression that some people have is that this is um,
a,
a blend of different things that produces a sort of a synergistic effect and
that hasn't been proven that if,
even if that hasn't been proven,
even if this is just a theoretical synergistic effect,
each individual nutrient that's in Alpha brain is absolutely been to been
proven,
absolutely has been proven to have a positive impact on some function of either
the human body,
mind or athletic performance.
There's a lot of shit that's referenced,
a lot of studies that are referenced on the Alpha Brain Science link.
So just check that out if you have any questions about this stuff.
That's where he got in a fight.
So the people on the line,
that's just a little bit of it.
It's just,
it's annoying that people just get so candy,
like right away.
Like people were just so insulted in country right away that just sometimes you
cannot give your energy to.
Yeah.
But I like it sometimes.
I like it and sometimes it's fun.
I like to smack them down,
but I don't,
I don't do it because I want to put an idea in their head of how stupid it is.
No.
Do you think they're going to go away thinking,
you know what,
let me rethink that.
Or they're just going to go,
I don't give a fucking idiot.
Ooh,
cool food.
I don't care how they,
how they take it.
That's up to them.
Yeah.
It's just that they're there in the first place.
They should be ostracized from any online community.
That's what I think.
I think really country shitty people,
she'd be ostracized and I think we should only encourage the kind of
communication,
like turning your body.
Yeah,
it's fun.
So when people get kind,
I call him stupid or you know,
or I'll call them [inaudible] or whatever.
But yeah,
the reason why I dealers,
I want them to feel it,
I want them to know this is that you don't do this.
This is a stupid way to behave.
You don't have to communicate your thoughts like this,
you know?
But then it's kind of hypocritical on my part because I'm kind of lashing out at
them the same way they're doing it to them,
man.
Never going to learn that lesson.
Of course not.
I'm an idiot.
So it's like you're just wasting your time with them.
You make yourself feel worse.
It's fun though sometimes.
Sometimes it lets you realize though.
It's like they will not get what you are saying.
There's no moment where the book fuck you're right.
Yeah,
I know it is.
It's weird.
Um,
anyway,
uh,
go to [inaudible] dot com and check out all the different supplements.
The ones,
the main ones I use are shroom,
tech,
sport and Alpha brain or you shroom tech sport.
All the time.
Before I work out,
I take four of those bitches and have ferocious workouts.
I have much more energy that I'm supposed to.
It's a,
it's awesome.
It's got a lot of B12 in it and cordyceps,
mushrooms.
All that is explained on,
on at.com.
O n.
N I t used the code name Rogan.
Get yourself 10% off.
Ari should figures here.
Dirty bitches,
Rogan experience Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Okay.
Hello everybody.
There it is.
That's going on buddy.
Um,
how are you?
I'm good.
What's cracking fear?
Headlining cobb's in San Francisco this Wednesday night strap the fuck in San
Fran.
Yeah,
that's huge.
That was a humongous club that I was,
I wrote it.
It's one of those cups of wrote off my head where it's like,
I don't need to,
if need be nice.
These management people,
I'll never before me on my own.
I ain't come up with a future and I'm not,
and I'm not going to hit.
It's too big,
you know?
That's hilarious.
No one's going to bring you up there to feature,
right.
It's like they're not just gonna.
I'm out.
I'm not going to go like to Baird also to Tempe.
It was like,
am I going here for $100 who else have you ever worked with?
Unlike a,
have you ever worked with the other headliners besides me,
Ralph a few times.
Paulie a few times and then like here are there other people you know but not
like didn't nobody else by brought me.
Everybody's doing it wrong because the way to deal right as you,
you bring a bunch of guys who are really funny man.
I'm seeing it already.
It's like I'm fighting to get just my friends in just to see if like they're
from there and had to like plead my cause it won't cost you one extra penny
please.
That's a comedy store comic that's going to be better than the guy you have like
pleased.
I think that's been,
it won't cost you anything.
And I'm like,
dude,
all right,
why don't they want you to do it?
They want to put their own guys,
which I get a lot of Neil in getting people to and also I can't,
cause I'm not a lot of costs.
I'm like anything extra now cause then it's like extra costs.
Well that's all that'll all change as long as he keeps selling tickets at all
changes.
But yeah,
there's,
there's a,
there's like a growth period when you start working in clubs where you start off
and you know you have to work with their people and then you're maybe allowed to
suggest to people but they like bring the MC or something like that and then
eventually it gets to a point where you can control the whole situation.
Yeah.
It's even just to like give something back.
Like I'm going to Philadelphia,
it was trying to get Eleanor Simona and just,
cause it's like,
hey,
if you want it to Patriot home.
Right,
right,
right.
Some guys like having,
trying to get into that club.
Do you think you can tell them how about that?
Yeah.
And Eleanor Simona both.
Great.
Yeah,
that'd be perfect.
Yeah.
I mean don't,
do they accept a audition videos?
Do they except video?
I don't know.
It's just so much easier when they actually go see you.
So it's like it brings some money in and they performed for a week.
They kill and it's like,
oh see I can look good the way I do it.
I said I just sort of take over the um,
like,
especially if it's like a theater or something like that or not.
Yeah,
you just take over the night.
So you own it from eight to 10 or whatever it is,
name.
They work out where all the money goes.
You know,
my management and everything does.
But I bring on the show.
So when you do a comedy club,
man,
I like to treat a common club was same way as your theater.
I don't have to come in and bring the opening show.
I don't want to have to work with a local guy.
And it doesn't mean that I don't love local comedy because I fucking do,
you know?
But I don't want to have to guess as to whether or not on my life,
the guy,
I don't know.
I have to guess as to whether or not he's crazy or he's really cool and
friendly.
A lot of them are going to be really cool and friendly.
Like we did this thing for the maximum tour where we went on the road.
We did like 22 gangs,
me and Charlie Murphy and John Half on.
And one of the cool parts about it was we met some really funny comics.
That's where we met Tom Segura.
Yeah.
Tom.
Josh McDermitt was a Phoenix guy.
We met him when we did the Tempe and we tried to get me into that.
Right.
And they were like,
fuck no.
They're like,
let's look him up.
And that I saw and they're like,
absolutely not.
Don't bring it up again.
It's not happening.
Yeah.
So in,
you know,
in the beginning it just,
uh,
it was,
it was great.
It was like a bunch of good guys,
like roof,
really funny,
local guys like Thompson girl.
But we had this one guy,
I think it was in Boston,
was it in Boston that we had that one guy who was an asshole.
There was like giving me the finger behind my back and he was,
he got really drunk and it was Boston.
It was Boston.
That guy was weird,
man.
He didn't do,
we got stuck in the green room with a crazy person.
He was,
the opening act was really weird.
I don't remember his name man,
but I remember getting him such weird vibe from everybody got these weird vibes
from him and he started getting really drunk.
I don't remember the dude,
I don't remember his name,
but I remember that was that possibility.
The possibility that it might not have been Boston.
Expound a fact.
I'm starting,
I don't want to say it's boss.
I can't remember what town it was now that I think there was so many in oven or
in a row.
It's really silly of me to say it was Boston.
If it was that it was not the Boston guy apologized.
Whoever it was.
When you think about people from Boston,
their minds,
your background.
Yeah,
maybe just
rolling eyes.
So many psychopaths.
I Dunno.
I don't mean it might not have been Boston.
Another think about it for the first I played the buzzing with you at Faneuil
hall at a comedy.
What was it called?
Um,
common connection if hall and a,
and just seeing your friends show up and then like they're starting to Yap.
Louder and louder.
And I'm like,
wait,
no,
this can't be real good.
Made to each other.
I grew up with sat there.
The problem it was savages.
Yeah.
It's like,
do we tell them to be quiet Howard?
Yeah.
Just drunk
fucking Chinese food.
Yeah.
I'm fucking starving.
People turning,
looking at what?
Yeah.
Well it's mostly my pal.
Jimmy did Telia Shimmy to Shelia gets a couple of drinks and then he gets crazy.
He's an awesome guy though.
They were fun people.
You know,
that's the thing about east coast people.
They,
there's a,
there's days,
an unmistakable extra energy that east coast people have,
you know,
whether it's Douchey or good or whatever it is.
There's a weird,
unmistakable,
little extra energy that east coast people trying to name it.
This weekend it was like to fucking whiteness.
It's just like,
no,
I don't know man.
It's a different thing.
It's a different,
people have a different attitude.
I don't know what it is,
man.
I wonder if it's the,
the,
um,
I think one of the problems with La being so big and so it's really big,
but we all have cars and so we're not like interacting with each other.
No,
not at all.
Whereas New York City is really big,
but everybody melts with everybody.
Everybody's subway and cabs and walking
and subway and calves at walking.
So I think it becomes a more healthy blend of people and everybody sort of,
you know,
there,
I think it's probably passed out a little heightened little heightened to be
aware of all the boats.
Like everybody has to be aware of that bullshit.
Not just the,
not just poor people.
Everybody has to look at all times.
Yeah.
There's always could be someone walking the streets of New York City in any
given place and time that's not supposed to be there.
It's not like he's a fence around it,
you know?
You know what I mean?
Criminals can get to like,
we're really rich,
old ladies are stepping out of billion dollar apartment building.
I'll talk about,
yeah,
I mean,
what's to stop them?
What's to stop them from doing that.
I mean,
are there cops that are constantly patrolling those little that advertisers
don't batches and the bus stops and park avenue there isn't.
Okay.
I don't want the homeless sleeping in them.
Whoa.
So let's say we're just,
none of us using anyway.
Wow.
That's where it's just a service I'm going to,
no,
I don't get it.
Oh my God.
That's ridiculous.
But that's what rich people get.
That's what they pay their taxes and stuff extra or whatever they pay.
That's why there isn't a real crime.
There was more cops presence.
Do they really have more cops though?
Is that legal?
So legal to have like more cops.
I don't know.
You're right.
It shouldn't be legal.
Right.
That seems weird.
But it's like they're the ones that get shit done to the donators and stuff,
but what is it?
Why do they have why given up on large portions of the city and it's okay.
Yeah.
That just didn't seem like it should be illegal,
right?
No.
They were like,
don't worry you guys here.
We'll,
we'll make sure to protect you.
Why am I,
why is their life worth more?
They always said that when the power went out that it would go back on in the
nice neighborhoods first.
Yeah.
And then,
yeah,
later downtown.
I don't know.
Yeah,
Um,
I don't know if they'll,
if they can actually do that,
can actually do that.
I don't know.
You'd think they would though.
I Bet I can get away with it.
How would they get away with it?
Well,
there's less crime there.
So at the same amount of patrol would keep it,
I don't know.
Yeah.
How do they damage?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
I just don't know if it's,
it must be,
but then you go to like to pay more taxes in one area and then you,
the police get paid more as I show more police presence,
smart,
really strong fire departments.
So we're gonna let's all pay a little more.
We'll get a better to fire department.
I don't know if it works that way.
Did you hear about this tag?
Don't know.
I'm an ignorant person when it comes to the allocation of taxes.
When it comes to town that the uh,
the uh,
citizens paid for the fire department and they all had to kick in something Max
like a voluntary extra cause they weren't making it and White House said no,
I don't know where this was.
They said we just can't afford that extra,
whatever it was.
The house caught fire and the fire department just put out the house that paid
and not the house that didn't pay.
Whoa.
Let it burn to the ground.
Oh my gosh.
I know where that was from.
Yeah.
So I'm,
we're in America though,
but like this year or last year,
that's fucked up.
That's fucked up.
Where they're like,
nope.
Nothing.
A persons house burned to the ground when you could have stopped it.
Could they have stopped it?
They could put it out somewhat.
Yeah.
It seemed like that,
I don't want to say they saw it.
Facts.
I mean it could have been just complete coincidence or fucked up Karma,
you know?
We don't know.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
It might've been more fucked up by the time they got there.
Then the other house that was next to him,
maybe we don't really know.
Right.
We're talking shit.
That was the story though.
I read the story.
That's the problem is talking shit.
We all talk,
we're all talking shit.
There's a doctor that was talking shit on one of the UFC fighters.
What'd he say?
Well,
he's talking about a child son and,
and um,
I think he referenced Frank Mir as well.
And I got into an argument with him about,
um,
on the underground with a,
with people about this argument about this article because he was saying that
these guys that are um,
the,
they need testosterone replacement therapy like that,
it's likely that they abused their body was steroids and that's why the tests
shut down.
Which can be true.
It's absolutely true that that can be one of the reasons is that a lot,
it's only one reason.
Another reason is head trauma.
And for whatever reason this guy didn't,
it didn't factor that in.
You know,
when he's talking about Frank Mir,
he started talking about Frank Mir being 33 years old.
What is the average 33 year old need?
Testosterone replacement therapy for the amount of head trauma that guy has
taken is quite substantial and to not factor that in and just to make an an
assessment on why someone needs and to only go towards the one possible
explanation like steroids,
which,
which is the sensationalistic,
uh,
explanation that's,
I think that's wrong and it's,
it's unfair to characterize fighters like that.
There's guys like James Tony for instance,
who had a real problem.
He was,
he had been hit in the head so many times.
It is.
Bonnie was like producing no testosterone.
It was trauma related there.
How do those travel or not?
Because they've no,
with him,
with James.
Tony didn't have a,
he didn't have a steroid issue.
I don't think it was just,
it was head Trump,
I mean steroids and that knocked the testosterone if you want to speak hi.
Yeah,
impact.
Like people have had it from car accidents.
People have had it from,
there's a lot of studies that have been done on it.
I don't,
I don't want to quote anything,
but I know that there's a guy named Dr. Mark Gordon.
He's the guy who works tonnage of you that thinks that fighting should be
illegal.
Not Illegal.
No,
but look,
I don't do it.
I mean,
if you're putting those people in danger like this that you're talking about,
no,
know that it's a choice.
It's a personal choice.
You know?
Look,
I,
I took that choice myself and I knew when I was 21 I was like,
I was in a weird situation.
There was nowhere to go with it.
I was competing and taekwondo and then I started kickboxing and once I started
kickboxing,
I realize that taekwondo was kind of bullshit.
It was,
there was a lot of holes in taekwondo.
There's a few techniques that are really good,
but the,
no punching to the face part with it as much.
The fact you can kick the fence,
Zack kicked the body parts of the body.
The body.
Yes,
yes.
You can punch the body
stupid.
You should be able to kick to the face.
No,
you can't kick to the legs either.
So you,
you allow people to develop this amazing dexterity with their legs,
this amazing ability to move with their legs and kick the kickers from taekwondo
or some of the most spectacular kickers.
But as a punch in the foot,
exactly as a style,
it's all fucked up because it's a wide open the eye,
their idea was that the legs produced the most power.
So if you get really proficient at hitting someone with your left,
someone with a leg,
it's way better than getting good at anything else.
So they said just get really good at head kicks.
That was the idea of the TACO window guys.
And you know,
they're right man.
Jesus,
sorry,
fuck son doing.
So their idea was that you just had to get really good at kicking.
A lot of people had a bottom wonky ideas about what was the best martial art
because the reality is the only way to tell was he fight.
And if you fight,
you're fighting most of the time to death back then.
So it was not a lot of information,
which it wasn't passed down like it is today with the UFC.
You know,
I'm sure if you went back in time and watch some fights from like a balance of
the year,
so they must have known head trauma coming in and out of this fucking day when
you're talking about,
but the people that developed martial arts had developed them in under real hand
to hand combat situations.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
sure.
There was a little training,
a little sparring and we'll practice.
Let's see how your Jujitsu helps you when a lion is attacking.
Well,
how about when a guy's coming to fucking raid your village?
Man,
you're,
you're fighting to the death.
You know,
a lot of,
uh,
Marshall back there,
a lot of martial arts,
we're sort of stuck in this sort of a period where they couldn't figure out
like,
what's the best shit.
Everybody had an argument.
Everybody was like really stubborn.
And it was almost,
it got to the point where people weren't even actively trying to find out what
the best stuff was.
They would just being zealots towards their style.
Perfect.
Something.
Yeah.
And then use that really well.
Most people.
Yeah.
When I would,
uh,
if I would try to train with someone else,
whether it was karate guys or anyone else,
my instructor would get angry at me.
Acting classes are like that.
We're like,
this is the best training.
Like why?
Just because you took it,
you happen to randomly take the best one says,
Ooh man,
say your best is not his best is not,
you know,
there's a lot of different people out there,
folks,
and everybody's got a brain and everybody's got an opinion and it's not,
you're not wrong or right.
It's just we all have different ways of enjoying this world.
I think it's becoming obvious,
the most important martial art list.
The best.
Well,
it's a very important that to get really boring.
I don't,
I don't agree with that because this guys like Charles Oliveira who's a really
bad ass Jujitsu guy.
He'd take him down and he's fucking strangling you.
He strangling you quick.
Really catches guys and triangles like a motherfucker,
man.
It's just,
it's going to make guys have a guard.
Like that guy.
I got half guard.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like a shoe.
Like a Shinier,
yeah.
Like a guy like that.
It's going to,
it's going to take a guy like that.
Who's the guy that always goes for the fucking lick things.
I'm an Ra.
He's terrifying.
Just go look as youtube clicks.
He just,
he just grabs you.
People are standing up over him and all of sudden good.
He is horrifying.
His leg locks are so good.
He just,
he just rips your knee upon it and you don't even have people cripples.
People pops her knees apart cause the way here to tap just nope.
Takes you shit apart.
You scream tap at the same time.
There's so many videos of him just screamed.
Tapping people.
Yeah.
He's terrifying to me.
I would not want to roll with that guy.
I get so scared when I see guys going for an ankle locks or knee bars.
It's such a fine line between,
you know,
nothing too broken.
Yeah.
It is a,
there's,
especially when it comes to heal hooks,
heel hooks are ridiculously quick to tear and damage.
The,
the,
you don't have much time to fight them off.
Your leg doesn't have much strength in that direction.
And what guy gets your heel under his armpit and he wrenches.
He has his legs wrapped around the upper portion of your leg so it isolates your
knee in between his legs and in between your upper arms and your upper arms,
have his heel hooked in the crook of your arm pit and you rip his knee apart.
You torque your body,
so body and a twisting action using your legs and your upper body.
It's your whole body against the really sensitive outer area of his joint and it
just tears the meniscus apart.
Snaps the ACL.
And how long did that take the hill?
Oh,
it's a fucking forever.
You might not ever be the same guy.
It's such a damaging,
wrenching way of tagging a neopod.
They're going to have to scoop some meniscus out.
They're going to have to reconstruct her ACL.
That'll be six months before you can even roll again.
20 years ago,
you're just done.
20 years ago you were done.
My friend Steve Graham,
you know Steve,
I love that dude.
He has had some ungodly amount of knee surgeries.
I think it's something like 18 he was on the US ski team back in the eighties
yeah,
that guy's great.
He ripped his knees apartment.
He went,
interviewed him for my podcast,
perfect guy and he told me so much fun stuff about doctors.
Yeah,
he's an awesome guy.
He is a,
I love that guy.
He's a one of my favorite human beings,
known him since the taekwondo days when I was a little kid.
He meant was really nice.
It's just nice and calm.
He's the best.
He's a great dude and he's super intelligent.
He's just a fun guy to talk to,
but he's had a gang,
a knee surgeries man from his king and I'm from skiing initially and the way
they used to reconstruct the leg was like they would take your hamstring and
they would take a big chunk of meat out of your hamstring and then they would
open you up like a fish and then they like fucking staple this new piece of meat
in place of it.
It didn't always work like that.
It didn't always work and sometimes you know,
you would have it for a little while.
It lasts for a little while and then a blow out again,
so he'd have to go back in,
they'd have to do it again.
So meanwhile they're taking it into that strip off your hamstring and maybe this
time it's your placement therapy.
Sort of like that show up.
Like that technology where you want to take a piece of meat from one spot and
move it to another party.
Yeah,
that's essentially
what they're doing.
Birth with my first one,
my first one,
they took a piece of meat from my patella tendon.
Where's your pants?
How to create,
it's the front tendon.
The front tendon is really big.
It's really thick and wine,
so they take a little sliver of that,
which is all you need for your ACL and they take a big chunk out of your kneecap
bone and your shin bone and then they drill holes in Saudi and screw that bone
into place.
Who just who?
That's the way to do these things.
Who was that?
Who was that guy that did that surgery?
Awesome,
dude.
Yeah,
it's amazing when you think about it.
I mean it's done now,
but who was the fourth test that an animal's fur.
Thank God for fucking doctors,
man.
Thank God for dudes who have figured out how to fucking fix shit and put things
back together again.
Doctor Gettleman when he was and he did such a great job with both my knees.
He was looking at the MRI.
I tell you this and it's just where it takes you through it.
Three d image of what's going on if you need,
and he's like a see what the torn there we got as a peaceful and just,
it's all the way around.
It's awesome.
How's it,
did they have this when you were in medical school?
It was,
no,
it just had the theory of it.
Wow.
He goes,
I had to learn it all like later.
If it makes it so much easier,
that guy get them in,
stitched me up twice.
He did my meniscus on my left knee and reconstructed my right knee.
He's about to do my second.
I mean really,
if I lived a hundred years ago it'd be completely useless.
You'd be dead by now.
I'd be dead.
Yeah,
probably I would be,
first of all,
I probably wouldn't have done all this stupid shit I did if I didn't think they
could fix it.
You know what I mean?
If that was your last straw,
every time I would've been like,
wait a minute man.
Good fucking make me a cripple.
You don't think about that shit though.
When you're young,
you don't think about it at all.
I didn't think about anything until the first time I injured myself and I
started and I was like,
Whoa,
I could break my body.
Like I tore my ACL and I was like,
okay,
this is broken now.
Like this.
It was wobbly and shit.
I was like this.
That was a really fucking fucked it up.
You had this thing and you fucked it up.
It's a weird feeling when a part of your body doesn't work anymore.
It wobble and we'd give out on me and I'd be like,
Whoa,
my new reality forever.
Yeah,
so I would wear a knee brace.
Sometimes that would help a little bit,
but the reality as it needed to be reconstructed,
it needed to be put back into place like Forrest Gump,
like Forrest Gump,
walking around
ACL brace.
It's actually pretty dope.
It's a,
it keeps your,
your knee and uh,
you know,
it's like,
it's a hard plastic thing that goes wrong.
Like a shell around your name.
Yeah.
It allows some guys who have torn ACL still even put off surgery for a little
while,
but eventually you're going to have to get it fixed.
They give you was talking about it keeps scrolling down after surgery.
Uh,
what a stocking stocking to keep the compression shorts when you're going to get
your knee operated on a week from today.
Fucking animal.
Tell everybody how you injured yourself standing up.
I uh,
I made the mistake of changing my shoes.
Then when I stood up was snap fluid.
Oh,
they told him he was just cartilage damage,
but she just stood up weird.
Just stood up playing basketball has changed my shoes,
stood up and just felt it.
Snap it.
She was saying that she was a failing body.
That's just something that shows it's time to trade it in.
So when you should get German engineering.
Yeah.
You know,
I just want to say because I'm in this sort of Internet thing about this Dr.
Benjamin Guy,
I have no ill will towards this man.
You know,
he uh,
he did write one thing saying that the UFC appeals to racism.
You wrote an article saying that heals to raise hills to racism.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Doctor wrote this.
Yeah.
Why doctor?
That's weird.
Yeah.
I love doctor.
Come on.
Jesus.
Damn good.
You have a mute button on your
head or thinks that to call someone like a week ago.
Um,
yeah,
I don't,
I mean I know his argument was really weird.
It was at the faces of the UFC are all white and up until a certain amount of
time there was no black ring card girl.
And if that girl went online and saw the horrible things that people write about
her,
which is true,
but you know what man,
that's just the Internet.
That's not saying that the UFC appeals to racism.
That's ridiculous.
Some of their biggest fans.
It was the biggest stars are black that appeals to racists.
It's doesn't appeal football,
racists.
It's a pocket court man.
It's a sport where you got culture mixing together with young athletes,
sort of burgers and it doesn't,
it's not,
there's nothing racist about it.
You know,
there was no black green car girls.
And what else?
His argument was that all the phases of the UFC were white,
meaning me and Dana White and Mike Goldberg and Bruce Buffer that because we're
white and because I,
you know,
I'm not black so I have no idea what it's like to be a black man.
I have no idea what it's like.
I have no idea what it's like to experience that kind of racist.
I would never pretend to know it,
but I do.
I do know that you could be reaching,
maybe you can hire like Freddy Loc hard on Repatha.
That's region.
I try sometimes when I've right here,
a report or something,
some black professor,
you know,
talking about like how something is racist.
And I'm like,
well let me think.
Let me really put myself in the place.
And sometimes I'm like,
yeah,
I can see how that could be bad.
Um,
like the constant demand for birth certificates from Obama and stuff like that.
It's like an stop enough that that can be construed as racism.
There's a guy who I'm hung in effigy of the president.
Did you hear about this fucking thing?
Some crazy motherfucker and mortal technique posted it on his Twitter and then I
retweeted it and all these people that have been asking to get immortal
technique in the podcast and I'll get them on settle down what somebody got.
So many people got mad at me on my message board because I wasn't responding.
There's like a million threads on that message board and yeah,
I look at things sometimes,
but sometimes when I get online and and look at things,
I'm in the middle of answering the phone and I'm trying to,
you know,
figuring out what the fuck
I'm doing and someone is screaming at me in the background,
probably get it now when I got more messages and less time to deal with it.
And if it requires any sort of response back,
it's like,
I'll do that later,
which means I might not do it at all.
Just forgot about it completely.
Yeah,
you get busy,
man.
Just too busy to do to deal with it,
you know,
so don't get shitty.
Especially people on my message board,
like,
you know,
there was people were saying I was being childish and immature because they
hadn't responded to their request to get it.
Mortal technique.
What does he say?
Huddle down.
That's never even heard of them.
I've heard of him.
I like him.
I like his rap.
You could probably put some of it,
you could probably put some of it online or you have a question to put on and
it's just like you're not interested.
Should you write back and say no thanks.
I mean,
I don't think he would be upset if we played a little bit of his music if you
want to play some of it.
But uh,
but I like it.
Shit.
He's like really like kind of a political radical,
very,
very intelligent dude I think.
And in really very knowledgeable about like,
you know,
a different shit that's gone down in South America.
And I've,
I've seen some of his interviews and,
uh,
he's,
he's a a pretty radical dude.
So,
uh,
I think,
it'd be a really interesting conversation,
but just stop being conti people.
It's not necessary.
I'm overdoing it today.
Yeah.
I don't know what it is today.
Let them get to you.
I'm so anti country,
but it started with this,
it started with the goddess not contain all the doctor who I think just what I
was trying to say is I'm not black.
I don't know what it's like to be black.
I wouldn't,
it wouldn't imagine what that racism feels like that he must've experienced
growing up.
So I would never discount that.
I just say it's reaching.
I say the saying that the UFC appeals to racism is reaching down.
It's crazy.
It's,
it's not right.
My friend Don came from Jamaica when it was 18,
maybe 17.
Uh,
came here.
So he wasn't raised with like the certain type of racism that we have.
And he said he sees a lot of his friends.
He's racist and sometimes,
but he said,
he says a lot of sports claim racism when they're like,
hey,
come on man.
That has nothing to do with race.
Unquestionably happens.
It's unquestionable that people claim racism in an unfair way.
It's,
it's a bounce back.
It's a bounce back from the blatant racism of the 50s and the forties and
whatever the fuck the,
you know,
the,
the entire generation of his ancestors had to go through.
I look,
I'm entirely sympathetic,
but I think as human beings,
in order to really grow,
we have to recognize what is and isn't racist.
This is not racist.
I don't believe the UFC has racist,
believe it appeals to racism.
I think it's a big stretch,
but so that I criticized,
I was minor league critical about that.
Really?
I just said it.
I thought it was a silly article and then there's this thing about saying that
these guys have done steroids and that's why they're balls of shutdown because
that's not necessarily true.
What are the odds?
What are the percentage odds?
I don't know.
It's very high for a lot of athletes.
Athletics,
if it is very possible,
if you weren't talking about a combat sport,
I would say very likely.
But with a combat sport,
you have to take into factor the very
damage that happens to the brain and how that affects your body's production of
testosterone and other hormones.
Human growth hormone,
it's the pituitary gland.
Pituitary gland apparently is easily upset by trauma.
And,
uh,
when people have had car accidents from trauma or from or from a steroid abuse,
stereotypical people who don't do steroids,
like a person in a car accident,
a person with frequent concussions from playing backyard football.
You know,
people like to tell from a fighter who does some steroids.
I say,
well,
it's hard.
It's hard with you tell it with,
if it's a fighter who does some steroids,
cause when you fuck around with steroids,
especially if you're someone who's not doing it under the supervision of a
doctor and you don't know what you're taking or which most of them aren't.
Uh,
if you're,
you know,
if you're going to be a young kid and do something illegal like that,
most of the time you're going to probably like get it from some guy.
You know,
what the gym or something shady like that.
But if they,
if they did do it that way,
they could potentially shut down their testicles.
I knew a dude who was like trying to have a,
a kid with his wife.
He was like 27 years old and he was always trying to,
could,
was a bodybuilder professional bodybuilder.
And he was enormous.
And then,
um,
he was trying to,
uh,
have a baby with his wife and he couldn't get pregnant.
[inaudible] shit was done really 27.
They just shut the party down.
He overwhelmed his body was so much testosterone in being a pro bodybuilder and
getting fucking monstrously huge.
I'm so jealous.
That sounds like a pro.
It was,
he was enormous.
He was enormous.
That guy.
But he had the balls of like a 75 year old man.
They were done.
There was no loads.
No swimmies.
It just shuts it cause it's like kicking so much that your body's like,
well we don't need this anymore.
We don't need to make it.
Your body's completely baffled.
Your body's like,
what the fuck is going on?
Why do we have like 10,000 times
the amount of these motherfuckers I around us,
you know,
like imagine like what testosterone is.
If testosterone was like thugs in your system,
on each red blood cell or each cell in your body is,
you know,
just uh,
they have different citizens and all of a sudden testosterone comes in.
Just thugs.
Just so much angry biker gangs with Mohawks and baseball bats and just
everything else.
Angels Gang.
Just flow.
Looks like that's slipping into your body and that mind movie or I'll come into
that village.
Oh,
what was that movie?
Mel Gibson.
Apocalypto.
Yeah.
They just come in and I'll one day,
boom,
that movie was fucking bad ass.
Oh yeah.
Mel Gibson is a crazy fuck,
but he knows how to make a movie that wasn't good.
My grandma knows how to make the a bit Braveheart too.
Yes,
he did.
Like he was like produced it or something like fuck.
Yeah.
I think,
I dunno if he wrote it or did.
He had a lot to do with it.
I don't know.
The only one that he'd lost me,
I was the passion of the Christ.
I was like,
okay,
well I'm saying that you didn't see it.
Oh my God.
It's fascinating.
I had a friend and said it wouldn't,
it wouldn't go see that or Apocalypto cause Mel Gibson was antisemite,
but he would go and pay for a ticket for happy feet and then walk over to that
one.
Ah,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
Oh that's smart.
That's a good protest.
I liked that.
That seems like a fair protest.
I'll see your money movie,
but you won't get the credit for it.
That's a good protest.
I agree with that protest.
You know,
I was like,
get out of that deal from the antisemites to give it to the happy few people.
I think he's just crazy.
I think that's what it is.
Yeah.
I don't think it's an anti Semite.
Oh,
I think it's antisemitism is released by his craziness.
Oh yeah.
Like it's already there,
but just like,
just let it go.
Really grow up with a crazy dad too.
Isn't his dad like a Holocaust denier?
Something like that.
Something weird like that
sect of the Catholic church or something like that.
Man,
he would just always,
it's weird when you find these guys out to be just funked up regular people.
Yeah.
Somebody said to Mel Gibson,
they were like,
um,
uh,
something like someone compared his behavior to the Holocaust and he goes,
well,
let's not deal with hypotheticals.
Why?
I didn't say that you have there that way
you can't say that.
Could you imagine?
Holy Shit.
All the writers would be like,
what could you imagine?
Holy Shit.
That's where
I would love it.
It'd be wrong to say it,
but I'd be like,
oh my God.
And there aren't a blatant like that.
Yeah,
that's ridiculous.
Jesus Christ.
Some people don't believe it happened.
Right.
There was some guy who makes his living as a Holocaust denier.
David something or I forget,
my dad works with the Holocaust museum in DC and he said the guy was trying to
make an appointment to go in there and like check it out so we can deny all the
parts of it.
Really?
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Did you ever see that movie?
Uh,
about a guy who he was,
I think it was called Dr Death.
He was a,
I'm a scientist that was uh,
he designed suicide,
uh,
assassination machines,
not assassination.
What do you call it if you kill some execution execution machines.
He designed his documentary on that.
Yeah.
And they brought him to one of the concentration camps.
I don't remember which one it was,
that,
where they claim to have Gad gas chambers.
And he was sort of like lending support to the idea that there was this,
these weren't capable of supporting the kind of a gas chambers that were
apparently he got misled this guy and he got used as a pawn in this weird
holocaust sort of it at least,
I don't know if it's a Holocaust denial movement,
but a minimalizing of the Hawk Cross
movement.
A lot of people say that it was like 50,000 people,
something like that,
which is still a staggering number when you think about it.
If you thought of 50,000 people,
ten nine eleven's Chu,
dude,
it happened just 1940s yeah,
1940s millions of Jews were killed.
Wrap your head around that.
What does it awesome?
What does that mean?
That he's had is good.
That's the only German thing that I know.
How scary with those people.
Could you imagine if we were living in that time complete power that could have
easily happened during our life.
We could have gotten a shit roll the dice and we're fucking plopped out in 1935
and you'd be right in the heart of that shit.
When you're a little boy,
it's easily possible.
You,
you are.
I easily could have been born into that world as my dad.
It's your dad.
Yeah,
crazy.
You're going to second grade.
Then all of a sudden she'll change,
doesn't you're going to go some work,
some other ghetto.
They were ready for processing,
which Christ,
I've never seen any of their movie or done any like,
I don't know.
It's a zero about the Holocaust is as fucking sad as that sounds.
I like,
what should I teach it in public high school?
Zero.
I don't remember any of it.
Of course I could probably be sleeping through a lot of,
they might have taught you.
I know that Todd Fitzgerald,
but I didn't read it until like way later.
I remember being
in class and we were going over,
uh,
the,
the concentration camps and they were described in the concentration camps and
they were describing what had happened.
And you know,
this was in the 1980s,
so it was only 40 years later,
40 years later.
It didn't seem like I was,
I went to school,
I went to high school in [inaudible] 81.
That was my first year in high school for 40 years before there was still going
on.
That's crazy.
So it was,
it was a weird dark feeling to read that.
I remember reading that and be like,
wow,
that's not that word.
I,
it's probably some of your mom's age was,
yeah.
Well,
my grandfather,
my grandfather worked in a factory that made parts for the atomic bomb.
I was like,
uh,
that's like,
that was the big thing around our house.
GRANDPA works in a factory that makes a part for the proud of that fuck.
Yeah.
It was like an accomplishment,
right?
Fuck yeah.
They were like,
nobody was like,
what are you doing?
You're going to kill so many humans with that.
You have to sabotage that.
Yeah.
They were happy that we won.
We dropped it on them.
We won.
Oh,
that's a fucking crazy time.
And that's not that long,
weird moral place to be in to say that it's our country.
So it's good.
It's weird.
The,
it's human.
It's weird to get shat out into the world where that's not going on anymore.
But it just went on.
So you,
your piece,
your,
you know,
everywhere you go,
it's peace.
And you know,
I was living in Newton,
Massachusetts and everything's pretty and nice houses and it's a nice
neighborhood.
But the reality is that just,
it was just a few decades ago that we were involved in some crazy war,
what they were dropping these things from the sky that harness the power of sons
and they just randomly dropped them down on cities like a socket randomly.
They just decided that's what they're going to use as their target.
I don't know what their logic was.
I think it was just,
it's a big city and they knew,
you know,
big enough to make a name,
not the biggest or something.
Or were they giant?
Just don't know about him any more because they've been wiped out.
I don't know.
Mean maybe it's like,
why wouldn't they drop it right on Tokyo?
I don't know.
Do people still live there?
Hiroshima there now?
I think so.
It's an habitable again,
I don't know.
I don't know how it works with nuclear energy as far as a bomb or what?
What?
You know what carries radiation longer?
I know the nuclear power issue,
it's the worst.
Is that the,
um,
the,
the waste and the byproducts of the nuclear power that that's it's got,
uh,
it's,
it's toxic for like a hundred thousand years and haven't seen atomic bomb.
A nuclear bomb cause some point they just changed the name of that.
Hmm.
Adam's Adam Energy and new use.
Nuclear energy.
Okay.
What do you,
what are you,
who are you?
Who are you and what have you done with Brian?
I'm looking over the Stevie wonder.
Look in motherfucker.
I'm trying not to cry.
What did you even say?
Yeah.
What did you say?
Isn't it?
What is the difference?
You know,
Tom?
Yeah.
I mean,
it's a nuclear energy splitting atoms.
I don't know.
I'm so stupid for this conversation.
Adam bomb a nuclear bomb.
They only say we haven't nukes now that nobody could use the word.
Maybe off I go to the Adam bumps face page says also known as the nuclear
button.
My space back slash slash also that points from nuclear.com and nuclear.com.
Do I officially need reading glasses?
Bryant Tuckey knew I knew a imax her out.
What are you thinking?
Or whatever they're called.
We don't even know what's going on.
I was puking all morning,
so I didn't get to see any of it.
So Brian was bullshit.
I think you either work but it got much or something's wrong with the computer.
Cause there's no way you weren't looking at that.
I seriously had been puking rail since 10:00 PM last night.
Uh,
but it looks like that just,
I don't know,
it looks like there's a new design with the retina display that's a lot
skinnier.
Yeah.
And it's a lot more expensive.
Did you got somebody video of the beaten Barack Obama toy?
They're telling the what?
It's Barack Obama,
a windup toy that jerks off.
Oh wait.
Oh,
okay.
There are different here.
Here's this Obama thing that jerks off.
They're just bright.
It's a little windup tool.
That's ridiculous.
There are a lot of sell that that's ridiculous.
Here's the answer to the atomic nuclear bomb.
A nuclear bomb means that all bombs that perform in a nuclear reaction,
these nuclear bombs are also called thermo nuclear weapons.
And atomic bomb is a kind of nuclear bombs and atomic bombs do nuclear fission,
which is more powerful hydrogen bombs.
Oh,
wow.
More powerful hydrogen bomb to do nuclear fusion.
Oh,
okay.
I see.
Uh,
I read the sentence wrong.
Atomic bombs do nuclear fission.
While more powerful hydrogen bombs do nuclear fusion and hydrogen bombs can be a
thousand times more powerful than an atomic bombs.
Oh,
okay.
Wow.
So it's a big jump up.
Jesus Christ.
1,000 times more powerful.
That's already pretty powerful.
That's so scary that that was,
we shouldn't have that kind of
destruction.
We shouldn't have that at our fingertips.
I was in class,
I'll,
I will not forget this.
I was at Newton south high school in class and the history teacher was telling
us about this shit and he was just weird dude.
Anyways,
real weird guy.
And as he's telling us about this shit and might not even been a history dude,
might have been a science guy.
And I remember thinking like,
what the fuck what they dropped one on who?
They just dropped it on the whole city.
I just blew up everyone.
Not like the police station.
It's hard to wrap your head around the farm.
Army barracks.
Yeah.
Everyone in the whole study.
Like,
I mean,
I don't know how many people died.
Killed the cows to keep,
we're fucked.
Yeah.
Everything's fucked.
They just,
it just,
it just dropped down from the sky and literally ended everything that was in
front of it.
What is that?
I wonder how many people that actually did kill look that up.
Yeah.
We need to find that out.
Kind of horrifying.
Seven.
How many people,
Brian?
Oh,
you're one of those guys.
You mother fucker.
You one of those guys.
Um,
I wonder,
that's how Robert will remember by his father last night.
That was so awkward.
What Robert William Matt provides father's alive.
Then it came in to watch watching last night.
Yeah.
What?
And they left like walking down the street like,
and he was,
it seemed like he was walking normal and stuff.
It's so weird.
Did you see any
hangs out at the comedy store?
66,000 people were killed in here of 66,060 6,000 people.
What about Nagasaki?
Cause they didn't get the message up to 66,000 no,
I think,
well yeah.
How many Nagasaki is
hundred.
I'm going to read that.
I was talking.
One's in a different page.
Let me find this here.
Your phone blows up a lot.
Ari.
Ari is at the COBB's in San Francisco.
Cops Comedies Day this Wednesday the 13th and then Sacramento right after that
to the punchline.
I go straight.
Yeah,
please come out San Francisco.
Come on out.
You dirty bitches.
30 pitches.
I don't want to or it's too far to drive.
You don't have to come fucking drive.
Do.
You can fly.
You could get there if you're close,
you could get there.
We've had people that flew out to the ice house shows for like from England.
Really has a fucking very strange.
It's weird because you're playing,
I'm like three days in advance.
Sometimes we don't.
Sometimes we do them like every Friday.
Oh yeah.
80,000 between 60 and 80,000 for the second one in Nagasaki.
Yeah.
That's so many people.
So many people.
Holy Shit.
That's scary.
It's just scary that it can happen just like that.
That's so many people.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah,
that is,
man.
If you get 300 people to a club,
you're like,
wow,
nice.
This place is packed.
Yeah.
60,000 yeah.
All dead on dead.
It's like that.
What the [inaudible] suffering,
right?
They're just done.
Yeah.
If you,
I don't think we can really get our head around that pile of people.
60,000 I can't.
It's really hard to rectify those.
That's why this Holocaust,
people say it's like a low number,
like that's still a lot of people.
It's insane.
It's more than a football stadium and you know what?
There's,
it's hard to argue that we didn't have to do something to end the war.
You know,
when people start talking about well and ended the war and ended saved American
lives,
how many American lives that said,
I don't know.
What was the second bottle about?
Yeah.
I don't know.
That's a good question too.
I don't have the answers to those questions,
but I do know that it worked and that we grew up in a really safe environment
because of that,
you know?
But I feel like we're all going to be safer for a little while until it just
complete destruction over at once.
You think so?
I mean at that,
if it starts,
it's not going to stop you.
Which,
which countries could be like,
let's not get involved.
We'll just let them seeing that we did that,
man.
We're the only country that's ever done that.
Yeah.
And we're like,
we can't trust these other countries.
Like we have the only proven track record of not being like trustworthy to have
one.
We certainly can't trust them to,
to drop too.
Yeah.
On Japan.
So tiny.
Yeah.
Japan's on that bag.
Damn.
Japan has had a lot of nuclear shit go down and it's lifetime.
They'll just,
the lifetime that we know about,
we dropped,
we dropped that stuff on Japan,
then put all the Japanese American citizens,
many concentration camps just to like,
yeah,
just got to make sure they look different.
That's why I didn't do the Germany.
It looked the same as us.
Wow.
That's crazy.
And then we can spot them.
It can push them out.
I'm sure Chinese people got put it in there to imagine what it must've been
like.
Don't growing up a German kid in America during World War II guys.
Geez,
she has to him on your side here.
Just cause my uncle is fighting over there.
Those stupid motherfuckers back then people were so,
hey,
so what are you up to air?
What are you up to?
Kraut
those dummies back then.
Yeah,
like what do you mean?
Even now when you have better technology,
I have no idea how to,
how to help the other side.
Well,
how many people with turbans?
How many Sikhs got beat up after nine 11.
How many people that had nothing to do with it?
It started being an Indian Muslim.
Indian.
Exactly.
Yeah,
exactly.
They're like,
what are you talking about?
I don't mind to racism.
Just let it be about the thing I'm in.
People are so dumb.
There's so many dummies out there,
man.
We've got so many domains.
It's weird though.
I get it though.
That week after nine 11,
whenever you saw like an American flag waving or something or heard the national
anthem,
you get all choked up.
I didn't,
I got creeped out.
Oh,
I would get,
when I saw the baseball games stuff,
I was like,
I don't know.
Get to me.
I,
um,
I'll tell you what happened to me,
man.
I,
I remember thinking right away that like,
you know what?
All right,
Holy Shit.
Some shit is going down.
You know,
this is why we have a strong military
and they're going to stop all this fucking thing.
But then,
you know,
as things sort of settled in,
what really got me disturbed the most was that all of a sudden I saw American
flags everywhere,
everywhere,
and I,
it sounds ridiculous,
but I just,
I remember thinking they could get these fucking people to do anything right
now.
Oh yeah.
I just thought of,
it's like,
wow,
it's so nice to all get behind each other in times of crisis.
This is what they,
you know,
if you want to believe neo-con conspiracy theories,
that's the,
the scariest one of all is that they had said that they need a Pearl Harbor,
a Modern Day Pearl Harbor in order to get us into Iraq.
This is a statement that someone had said before September 11th ever happened.
When you start thinking about that,
that kind of shit really freaks me out and blows my fucking,
when they realize they can get stuff done.
When I,
when I saw all those flags,
when even I remember thinking,
yeah,
it does feel good to be American.
Yeah,
I do believe this is the greatest country of all time.
But if you let these mother fuckers know that you're their bitch like this,
they're gonna drag us into something.
You know?
You all of a sudden are just fucking,
I'm ready to go gung Ho and ready to go.
You gotta be careful.
Easy.
Why?
Why is anybody blowing up the fucking towers in the first place?
Why are they mad at us?
What the fuck's going on?
You know,
I'm just getting mad at us because they hate our ways.
Like what does that mean?
Who's that angry over our ways.
It's ridiculous.
What are you ever wait?
Someone's England.
So our ways of not being where we,
you know,
being where we're not supposed to,
but that's the stuff they don't really care that we're not that were,
that were pagans.
It's how it's always been.
It's like it's all done under the guise of protection.
You've been in Brazil?
Yeah.
You're kidding me.
Like they don't care about that stuff.
What do they care about that were in there?
I don't know,
man.
I don't know what,
how,
how they keep this hustle role and
it's quite impressive.
You know,
it's quite impressive and now everyone's got to go to work and just deal with
the day to day stuff.
Most people don't have time to deal with me,
like saying what's up?
We're way too busy.
It's just a,
it's you wonder,
you know,
there's so much shit's getting stirred up overseas.
You know,
like a wonder how's it ever going to smooth out that was the world ever going to
come to peace?
How is Europe going to get his economic shit together?
How is that gonna Fall Middle East?
Like what do they have to do to get it right?
And I was like,
man,
you know what?
Honestly,
I can't see a way we could.
They do.
What could they do?
It's going to take decades.
It's going to take generation,
much generations teaching less hate through each one are together and it's going
to help them the most.
[inaudible] the Internet is going to help them because time and time again,
they're going to realize that,
oh,
this is just something that you know,
someone believes in and someone has it created.
That's what took it off the Internet end and then it was done.
Really shouldn't have to that people saw what was out there.
Dude,
when they,
when that guy fucking stabbed a stick up,
his ass was stabbing his asshole with a stick in it.
I don't think it was a band that was it.
A man that was a knife attached to.
I
thought they said it was a stick.
I'm sure the Internet will tell up close to something like,
did that dude,
I gotta go pee out of my penis.
Okay,
go ahead.
How would you a type that in on Google?
What did Kadafi have stuck off his ass?
He asked that,
but stamp copy.
This is one that you don't even need butthole.
Fort Brian into it.
Hm.
Uh,
wow.
Gadhafi sodomized in his last moments.
I felt like I sat in my eyes last night.
Yeah.
You last night,
you,
uh,
had some bad Sushi and my frame.
What's happening,
what happened to you?
You got this sickness is the worst too.
It was one of those where you're shitting and then you need to puke.
And so I didn't want to puke in my bath tub,
so I had to like stand up real quick and turn around and then puke on my shit.
And that's the worst.
Oh you pooped.
And then you had to puke on top of your poop.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
ass smell to that.
And then I would go to sleep cause I,
I was shy.
I was freezing.
It was like I was in sweatshirts and like blankets around me and stuff like
that.
And then suddenly I start getting really hot and sweaty and I wake up and then I
was like,
oh my God,
I have to puke again.
And I would stand up real quick and then I'd stand up too quick.
So I'd get fainty and then I'd have to lay down while puking on my bathroom
floor about puking on my,
on my face.
It was.
It was the most,
it was the most disturbing horror movie I've ever seen in my life.
Okay.
It was a stick.
It was thick.
It was a stick up his ass.
They got those pants.
Well actually some people were saying it could be a stick or could be a knife or
it could be the end of a gun.
It's very blurry but more it seems like more people think it's a stick.
This is a good investment.
Makes Sense.
You know why?
I think it's a stick cause he's still standing.
I got get the guys like trying to shove the stick up his ass.
Whereas if it was a knife,
if I didn't want,
the guy would be in massive agony.
Somebody said like,
how did he shock that?
It was just like it was already been stabbed a bunch.
That was the weird moment when they caught him alive.
I was like,
they caught him alive and then he was dead.
hmm.
It feels not as satisfying.
Reeling.
I was looking at satisfying.
That's the best way a guy like that could ever get it.
The guy would suppress.
The people forever and they finally get ahold of them.
They can't believe they actually have them.
They're going nuts.
They're shooting the fucking air and then they stab him in the ass with a stick
and then they fall.
Shoot him in the chest.
Are you kidding?
That's the most satisfying way that guy out it seems like,
all right.
Put it before stats.
I guess.
You're right.
It doesn't do anything better.
They'd have to kill him,
right?
Yeah,
and who knows what they're going to find out.
If they do put them in front of that,
we might not even want to know.
You know,
we might not even want to protect these generals or something like what,
what involvement our country's had with him and we'd always want to know,
oh,
I think most people would sleep better if
they didn't know.
They didn't know the shit that we have to do just to keep this country running.
I'm scared.
I'm sorry.
I was careful about that.
The other weird thing is though,
everybody's always been scared.
I was listening to these tapes.
It was a hunters Thompson lecture from Boulder,
Colorado.
In the 70s.
And it's fun.
It's fun to listen to him.
He's a fun guy,
you know,
and I love her,
his,
uh,
his writing.
So I always enjoyed hearing.
I'm getting interviewed,
but it was interesting that in 1970 when this was going down,
whenever he had this interview,
um,
that was a long ass time ago.
Man,
who's,
you know,
talking about it dissolve.
The country's going to shit,
everything's falling apart.
And I guess he's right.
I mean,
it may be,
it's a slow slide.
I heard something recently,
anything that was invented after you hit 35 is ruining everything.
You just can't accept this new technology in your life.
And it's always been that way and it always will be that way.
That's a good point.
I don't buy it,
but that's funny.
I mean,
I don't want to accept the Internet.
Yeah.
John Anthony West,
that Egyptologists Dude,
very controversial,
uh,
episode of the podcast,
by the way.
Lots of chatter on the Internet.
Um,
anyway,
uh,
he,
that I could barely explain fram damn.
How key could see yes,
you had to go to Ustream.
I had to like spell it out,
so really there's a link on my Twitter.
Go check that.
I couldn't do that.
That bathroom fan sound that was going through the whole exhaust computer.
He had like a fucking 1984 at HP.
Yeah.
With his crazy fan that would kick in.
I mean,
I've never had a cool him off the fan.
Yeah,
of course.
It was ridiculous.
And that the advents in those,
yes.
To let the fan.
Yeah.
Shout yeah.
A lot of dudes had a water cooled machines to the slaughter and your computer.
Yeah.
I had one of those for a while,
but it kept fucking up.
Man Just wouldn't work.
Right.
I had to get it repaired and then I gave it to you.
Or give it to you or.gov document went off with it.
That was when I was trying to clear myself of gaming equipment too.
That's what you do.
You're like,
I can't trust myself.
Just get it away.
Just fucking,
I had a separate myself.
I your question go.
It's about,
do you think people can outgrow and addiction,
like have it less than in their older age,
in the way that just like you were like super addicted to gaming and then at
some point you're like,
no,
I can handle this now.
Well,
you know the alcoholics anonymous people have one very good point in that what
you do is you sort of separate your yourself from this one addiction that you
have and get addicted,
addicted to something positive instead.
You know?
So it's like you have to have,
like for me,
I have to have something that I'm obsessed with our half day.
I would prefer it to be life before it to be the intricacies of the universe and
the weirdness of the quantum world and the fucking strangeness of Outer Space
and Bacteria on life.
And I would prefer that to be what I'm fascinated by all the time.
But every now and then something will divert my attention and I,
my fucking stupid brain.
Someone's Twitter.
Well,
it could be that,
but that's just,
that's just fun.
That's like sport or like what the stupid,
like a game video games.
You know,
video games are big one.
Jujitsu could be a big one.
She just as hard because of the fee,
it's so physically demanding.
It's hard to really get addicted to something you can play for 10 straight
hours.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Video Games are fucking incredible,
man.
Video Games today,
there's so involving,
you know,
there's so much to them.
I feel like it's possible.
It'd be less than to have your addictions lessened over time.
Just like just calming down in general.
Just saying like everybody,
like everybody didn't know you.
I know it's not addiction,
but we'd get tanked every Friday and Saturday or not.
Yeah.
And then at some point people sort of grow up and they stop needing that.
Well,
I think so many people,
when you know,
you growing up,
especially,
you're just so wound up and confused and you don't know what the fuck the future
holds and you can't even believe you're away from your parents yet.
No.
And you're drinking,
man,
you want a fucking woo.
You want to,
you want to be a goddamn person.
You know?
We're all suppressed by our parents,
except for Brian.
Brian was just loner free in the world.
He's sleeping.
He's just to eat shit til we can put Brian [inaudible].
Brian,
are we doing a show at the ice house Wednesday night?
I have no idea.
I say yes.
Let's make this happen.
I'll find the ice house ones.
Then I bill burns doing the podcast Wednesday too,
so I'll have him come down to the ice house before and we'll do that.
Stay.
You heard it ladies and gentlemen.
Boom.
That's as crazy as it gets and I'll be in nor cal this weekend.
This whole weekend.
Yeah.
What are you doing?
You're doing cobb's on Wednesday night.
I send you straight to Sacramento to the punchline.
Oh shit son.
That Sacramento punchlines bad ass.
That's a great club.
It's a cooling.
It's perfect.
Perfect sized.
And they've got that outlet store.
I forget what now.
It was like Neiman Marcus outlet or someone of those.
That's a Nordstrom rack.
That's what,
that's a shady little area though.
Yeah,
but now that 24 hour Starbucks that you love so much.
but that walk across the store feels dark.
Yeah.
That walk across the street from the hotel to the,
to the comedy club.
I saw somebody in Sacramento that's like a mathy area.
We saw somebody was in the car with all of us,
but we saw somebody sitting on an embankment pissing like,
like up,
like in an arc and then just running his hand through the,
and I'm like,
wow.
Like it was like fire that he couldn't,
you know how you run your hand over a flame?
Yeah.
So he was doing that over the as if the piste wasn't touching his hand.
Wow.
But it was,
it was just pissing on his hand and the ground in front of them.
That's ridiculous.
We tell the guy just like walking,
it was like 72 but just covered in sweat.
Oh,
I forgot about that.
Mathie Mathie it's just math.
Yeah.
There's some mathy Spock's man.
You know,
cause a lot of those weird California towns on the way to Vegas where you could
just take a,
you know,
let's go see there's food this way.
You know,
take a little ride off the highway.
I think I might start renting a car when I go to these places.
They're,
they're not that expensive.
In Columbus.
My car was,
uh,
how much?
$19 or $11 a day for the cheapest car.
Yeah.
And it's like,
all right that,
that'll let me be mobile enough that I could go downtown Sacramento or like that
instead of being stuck in an area,
I always run a car.
Yeah.
It's worth it for me.
I just,
I don't,
I don't want to have to deal with being stranded.
I always,
let's get out of here.
Okay.
Is escalades are expensive,
but you don't trust that he's got diarrhea and you say chest as far as like a
you son,
I'm going to ruin your underwear.
That's about what's going to happen.
The son of a bitch
never trust they got a man tampon in,
so just have to change that.
How dare you?
Oh my God,
I love my new car.
I got that Volkswagen beetle.
Yeah.
I didn't know that.
The Volkswagen beetle has the engine in the front now.
It's cool looking car.
Have you seen it?
The beetle as soon as the cool.
It's a dope little car man.
I'm like,
that seat is surprisingly roomy as the old design.
They redesigned it and it,
cause I guess they,
the old one used to have like a flower pot where you a little flower in it.
And I was like,
he designed for girl a vase.
Like it was totally designed for girls and that's why I never really liked the
beetle before,
but they redesigned it this year and they're trying to make was optional.
You have to get the,
why don't we all start saying,
why don't we all sorts say so the new one that I got,
it looks like a Porsche though.
Like in the inside.
Like it's very racy.
And what kind of containers does it have inside?
It didn't have any of those vegetables.
Can you grow inside the car?
It doesn't,
it just has a peacock feather tickling the balls with,
oh,
we had peacocks where I grew up and uh,
we had this lattice work in this coop that we had.
Maybe I'll get two peacocks and a bunch of chickens
and they would stick their head through the lattice work to eat the grass right
outside.
And the foxes would just wait for it and swipe no head.
So you'd find all these things with like no heads,
bodies head's gone.
Balis was inside or bloody buried it in the back.
Wow.
There is all that.
I grew up in the farm.
I grew up in the suburbs.
They ate flamingo heads.
Bigdog peacock heads,
Flamingo Flamingo.
That'd be weird birds,
man.
That is why did we know what,
what?
You know what caused them that developed and just the male to female,
right?
That's not,
I leave,
it's the male,
the male to attract a female to attract the female.
Can you just make a smell or something?
Fucking you put on a dope bash,
show that,
but that's
when I saw,
I once saw a drunk semi homeless guy outside the s the saddle ranch at like one
30 in the morning.
And he was just like dancing or the drunk drunk dad.
Yeah.
It could be Hobo could not be.
And I'm like,
Oh,
you're,
you're peacocking they're trying to attract a mate right now and the only method
you have.
Yeah,
that's what they look at.
What it's trying to do.
Something to shine.
Yeah.
But the peak guy puts up this crazy fee.
Look at me.
Look how pretty you make a noise too.
I saw a Pika again,
a fight with a bumper.
Like attack her bumper.
Yeah.
It was a chrome bumper and he thought the promos another peacock fucking idiot
and make this road noise.
Donk donk just get smashed himself.
He,
he dunked the bumper a couple times.
I couldn't figure out why.
You know,
it was like a truck bumper.
So it was a pretty wide bumper look.
A little,
a little mirror coming out of him every time he headbutted his fucking mirror a
few times a pecked at it.
It was just his instinct and he's like,
you win.
Yeah.
It's like not like that peacock in another dimension that's trapped inside.
This mirror was fucking with them.
Also,
the only way he would have read bad vibes and that peacock is if they were
coming off himself.
That's right.
Yo maybe fast.
Right?
Yo and you pointed others,
you'll go three fingers are pointing back at you.
I smell fear.
Desperation.
Y'All ain't even son.
I should've listened to you.
You guys.
Did you show yourself?
Can I get him to the bathroom?
You settled down.
You need to go to the bathroom.
I think I have a pretty good,
it'd make poopy expected him pretty good.
It's not talking about that anymore though.
Okay.
Silly Bitch.
Uh,
I listen to the recording from my city finally.
Yeah,
I'm scared.
It's actually like a month.
Oh yeah.
It's weird.
Right?
Cause it is what it is.
I'm so,
I was like,
felt like that's good.
But that might,
but if I hear it and it's not,
I'll be just be so disappointed.
That's good.
And I look and the other sets,
the first set,
I thought it was like worthless.
It was like,
oh,
this is actually really good.
I always member like the last tower,
right?
Like end or just certain moments or one person's face,
you know,
it makes me feel like
it just gets in your head.
So you're,
that's,
it's weird.
Are you left with one memory of something?
Like what?
Well,
they did this.
I remember having a tape I open predict Johansen once or did a guest spot.
I believe I opened for him and I'm remembering,
I was like,
fuck,
that was a bad crowd.
And then heard the tape after the full tape,
I'm gonna get a tape change and it was kill,
kill,
kill.
And then the last joke just was like,
so,
and I just felt like what a wasted opportunity.
But I forgot all about the first part of it.
Yeah.
When I say,
remember that last part,
if I have a joke that eats a dick,
that's all you sound wrong.
I already know the other jokes are good,
but it's like infectious.
It applies to the other jokes now.
It's just a shitty set.
Well,
they hate it cause you don't ever want to be that.
You don't ever want to have a set that's that sloppy or that's that,
uh,
for failure.
You don't want to have a set where,
uh,
a joke,
major bombs.
It's like,
dammit.
Like,
especially if it's like,
as they were like,
great job.
You're like,
yeah,
but you didn't see,
what about the middle two minutes?
Look for when you're first creating a bit and um,
you have like sort of a set order where you did the way you do the bit what
folks,
a lot of folks who understand Ari and I have a real similar writing styles in
that we
do a,
we have like a concept of shit and then a lot of times we just work it out on
stage.
I feel like there's definitely weaknesses to that.
I mean not being prepared as weak but like,
uh,
but I think it adds a sense of like,
this is just me talking to you guys right now because you don't have to set or
it doesn't sound like,
so I was at the store today and I,
you know,
I think it's,
I think it's good to do.
It's certainly good to write a,
I'm a big proponent of,
of actually just sitting down and writing.
But I also think is also think it's good to fuck around on stage with an idea
because it kind of under the gun.
Yeah.
You're already [inaudible] groove.
You already got people laughing at you and it's like you'll find the jokes in
there,
man.
Just let them empty yourself and find the jokes in there and now they're there.
They're there,
they're there because you've already,
you've already got the framework.
There's that moment of like of like a,
and if people talk about this,
you know,
but it's like there's that moment of like,
oh that needs a better laugh and you have a two second window in order to get
that laugh when you have one.
But now it's like your brain is just overdrive all hands on deck.
Let's get something heavy known then and just nail it.
Oh yeah.
And you're like,
that's keeping,
and you're like,
thank God I recorded this so I can go back and listen to that shit so many
times.
It's like a lot of the lines and we'll come to you when you're discussing,
uh,
like if,
if you put yourself under the gun like that,
you,
those,
those lines,
they almost looked like gifts from the universe.
It's like sometimes you'll say them and they'll come out as if you would
rehearse them as if you plotted it out and then it starts sounding worse.
You know,
like,
let me go back to that first time I did it.
Yeah.
That's the problem though.
When when when I was kind of saying is like you'll,
you'll have a joke and you'll have a new joke and then you,
when you,
when you start using it,
it becomes like sort of a tool in your act.
At least for me it does.
And then I started fucking around with it.
Like how can I make this tool work better?
Well,
I might fuck up the tool.
I'm trying to make it work better.
I might break the tool.
I might go,
oh,
I can't say it that way because then this is make,
oh yeah,
exactly.
You mess up something else.
And so then I'll have to,
you know,
then you have to correct.
I hate,
I don't like that when no one does.
When you,
when you,
I know you're just like me and that when people actually pay money to see you do
stand up,
you want to be on the best fucking show you can put on because I think we're
both kind of blown away that people would pay to see us talk.
Yeah.
Every time
I,
plus we've both done clubs for so long and then it's almost like,
you know,
you can just get this for free every night.
Like we don't,
but you can't really write.
They can't.
Like I remember David Taylor had to explain to us like,
you know those free comedy star passes to other people,
that's actually worth something to us.
It's just stuff to put in your joints.
Well they're like,
yeah,
the store is going to use it.
The stories are real unusual example as is the seller and you know as as the
Improv on Melrose do so few clubs,
but it's like,
like man,
the store,
especially because the store doesn't do weekly headliners,
you know,
almost every other club does weekly headliners except actually I guess the laugh
factory.
They don't really do that.
I write,
they have a weekly headliners situation when they have a market now.
So they have a showcase show very similar to the comic store show on Friday and
Saturdays.
Yeah,
that's,
I think just ongoing.
They'll have like a few different shows,
like you've got to clear out after awhile,
but in profit on that too,
they clear out.
But the comedy store keeps it running.
They're the only one that keeps it running.
It's just really interesting and it creates an environment like no other because
you may,
they very well go on stage at one o'clock in the morning to a group of people
that have been there for five hours.
Yeah.
So tired.
And you're like,
why isn't this one?
It's like too,
there's another way to,
it's so hard to connect with them at that stage.
It's,
it's a very,
um,
it's a,
it's like running with weights on,
that's why everyone who comes out of there sounds like there really legitimately
talking to you because you have to be that connected.
It's so hard to do a bit late at night.
Yeah.
You know one time it's got to sound like you talk.
A lot of my favorite things about going to the comic store,
I don't think I've ever talked to about this,
was that a Paul Mooney did not like me when he first met me.
Really?
He didn't talk.
He didn't,
it didn't not like me.
He just didn't take to,
it just didn't,
it just wasn't,
it wasn't cool to me for,
I remember introducing them and I don't remember how I introduce him and I gave
him this really nice introduction and when he wasn't flowery enough for him,
he looked at me like,
oh fucked up when it may is my act.
I Dunno who the fuck you know,
who the fuck knows whatever it was.
But when I first,
I don't know what the word the phrase gained his respect or got them to laugh at
me or whatever it was,
it was only like three people in the audience and he came up to me afterwards he
goes,
that's what I knew you was a real comic,
like three motherfuckers.
You just went up there to three motherfuckers and you lit that place up.
Paul Mooney with time and you and I was like,
wow,
I can't believe I'm getting a fucking compliment from Paul Mooney.
You lit those motherfuckers up.
He was a fun guy to watch,
man.
That guy knows how to command a crowd.
Yeah,
he's the one thing I saw like work in that booth.
You get to see a lot of comments to see the mistakes they make.
See the things we're doing right.
I remember saying,
Ahhh,
who's Mr. Curry?
Uh,
Cooper.
No.
Hanging with Mr. Cooper.
Mark Curry Marker.
Mr Gary with Mr. Curry.
What he's on.
What a fucking nice guy.
He is.
Mark Curry hanging with Mr Cooper's like the Nice,
Super Nice,
but I saw him three nights in a row and I,
the first night I just enjoyed it.
Like it came one day,
you haven't been there.
And then he came,
I was like,
oh,
that was funny.
The second night,
like in Jordan again,
it was the same material.
And third night I knew that I know the jokes so I just see the technique he was
using and I saw him like,
oh you missed a tagline there.
And then he like stop for a second and be like,
oh you know what else I don't realize like Oh you,
you pretended to remember that
same thing.
And with Mooney I saw him have a command over the audience like nobody else.
I saw before we even touch the mic,
everyone had this thing of like there were getting up to leave cause they all go
on after 1112.
Yeah.
But like start to stand up.
They'll go,
oh,
hold on a second.
And it's sit back down to watch him before we even says a word.
I don't know how he did it was the first five minutes I'll always watch.
It gets people,
it gets them,
he makes them operate on his level
for whatever reason he makes them.
Uh,
he makes them come to him.
He taught me this thing once where he said,
uh,
I saw him do a bit about,
let's say Aretha Franklin a few times,
and every time it's like,
oh,
what's that pitcher's name?
Don't have to be told,
what's his name from,
you know,
from something.
And they'll say it.
The crowd will say,
Oh yeah,
don't get me started on Teresa.
But I'm like,
why do you do that?
Do you remember?
Right.
He goes,
partially,
uh,
to sound like I'm just thinking about it and partially to seem like I'm better
than her.
I can't be bothered to know her name.
It puts you in a power position.
That's it.
He said,
yeah.
Oh,
that's funny.
Yeah.
To The dad paid his bid about,
he got his nigger wakeup call.
They're gonna wake up.
God Damn,
that's a good,
holy shit.
That's a good bit
about how you thought you were better than other elder,
the black people.
And then you've got your dude,
Paul Mooneys,
a motherfucker.
Johnny Sanchez came in after him once and just did a Pomone impression.
He goes,
oh,
he goes,
he's been around for so long.
I knew it was barely,
it was old matches.
Matches.
Got the Nigga wake up,
call a blinking.
You think you know that you're all going to sneak a wake up call.
Johnny Sanchez,
he was at the,
uh,
um,
ice house.
He says,
hi.
If you want to see him,
it says,
he said,
oh,
it was cool to see him,
man.
Yeah,
it was fun to see him.
He looked really happy.
He's got a kid.
Yeah.
Powerful.
Johnny Sanchez or Daddy.
Jesus.
You say Jesus.
Um,
uh,
can't picture him as a father.
He was thinking,
it just seems like so much work.
Uh,
it is a lot of work,
man.
There's no doubt about it.
You know,
it's probably not for Ari.
Shaffir hyperventilate a little bit.
Every time I think about it,
about having a child,
I think about the actual process of like having to run after one and pick it up
for a second.
I'm do it.
It's a lot of work,
but the reality of it is that the experience of raising children is incredibly
rewarding.
It's a,
it's a beautiful feeling to have like this little person that you love and that
you play with and hang out with.
And I look after,
you know,
as long as your check is into it and you're into her and you know,
you really love each other and you're financially stable mean if,
if you're not,
I mean,
people get by when they're not,
but I mean,
the,
the ideal way to do it is to do,
what do you think of people who've been in their kids or what,
what does that,
they don't,
they don't feel the same joy.
People are broken.
There's a lot of people.
It's a lot of people.
It's not like,
oh wow.
It's not the majority.
No,
it's not that majority.
You got to think when you say a lot what that means because there's 7 billion
people on the planet.
Man,
there's so many to get information.
It's happened a few times,
but it's like thousands and thousands of people right now or I don't know what
the real numbers are.
Do you do,
you know,
um,
I don't think we need to know him to know that it does.
Definitely happens.
I think so.
Do you think those people just don't broken?
Just they don't get that rape?
Why do people commit murder?
Why do people,
why do people become pedophiles?
Why do people rob banks,
you know,
why,
why do people think the pedophiles,
I didn't want to call it a sickness.
I think that's just a detail to you that you're super into that society.
Society has told you it's wrong and they would all agree that it's wrong,
but it's like fuck,
I'm still,
that's what I get.
Boners on.
That is interesting you brought that up because there was a youtube video that
somebody posted up on my board and uh,
it was asking the question of whether or not most men are pedophiles.
And it's a really interesting,
is the dude who put it on a and z maybe cause you think they would be,
if not Brian put that,
pulled this up because it's really kind of interesting.
Um,
look on youtube for are all men pedophiles question mark.
Yes.
Exclamation point.
And it's this guy and it's a really interesting,
um,
sort of a study that they've done about how man become attracted to women at 16.
And that's what your level always stays.
And it's because they reached puberty.
When they've reached puberty,
they reached the age of sexual maturity.
Whereas men don't reach the age of puberty and sexual maturity,
whether until they're 18.
That's not it.
That's my friends.
People who cheat,
they cheat with whoever they could get before they became famous bite when they
became sexualized.
So then you become famous all of a sudden your bank nines and tens,
but the one who cheat with is just who you naturally innately you can get.
It's not tiger woods.
This case he was,
he was going crazy with like the hottest girls in the world I suppose you get.
Yeah.
I wonder if he was fucking high when he was young.
He wasn't,
he wasn't like an amateur.
All Americans to the hottest girls in la,
but there's some really hot girls.
Those are,
those are pretty,
but he was also fucking a Denny's.
Wait,
listen,
listen.
Right.
My boy,
j w e is just done a documentary titled all men pedophiles.
I'm death.
What?
Go ahead.
Do this documentary.
Yes,
we,
oh,
okay.
Tell us what the documentary is about.
Okay.
Well I just want to say the answer is yes and no.
The general pop,
the definition of a pedophile is somebody who's attracted to somebody under 18
and then yes,
uh,
almost all men would fall under that category.
But to professional definition is someone who's attracted to children before
puberty
because in your documentary said that average mind,
I'm an average,
mine finds girls that are 16 years old.
I attracted,
yeah,
around the age of 16
and then you went back into historical times then showing us that puberty
usually happens for girls around 60,
they hit puberty.
So they,
they're physically ready to have sex and that's kind of what pulls us in.
Yeah,
puberty actually finishes.
So it's already finished around exit.
So there is nothing more physically that can happen sexually that will make you
better.
And reproduction.
Physically women are mature at 16,
but men are mature at 18 and it's a man's world.
So men rule apply to women as well.
You don't find,
you don't think it's a
25 30 man
positive,
but a 16 year old
what men formed their sexuality later.
So,
so what does that mean?
Well,
the age of consent is 18 because that's when a man's mature sexually.
Okay.
But a woman is mature sexually at 16 that's what he's saying.
So what did the name,
it's a man's world.
What does that mean?
Well,
because we used that as the age of maturity for women
to have sex before she's 16 they need ideas argument
until she essentially was 16 rather than 18 well it's 18 though,
right?
Yeah,
she'll be 16 is that what you're saying?
because that's what own sexuality.
Well it should be.
Certainly if it's an 18 year old boy and 16 year old girl,
but if it's a 40 year old guy in a 16 year old girl,
no,
I don't think so.
I think,
I think the,
there's a an age span where shit gets paid 18 creepy and manipulative.
Doesn't it feel like that at 18 to 50 year old guy?
I could bang an 18 year old or 18 year old also.
I think it should.
I think it should,
don't you?
I'm just going to certain percentage of year.
It's like,
I mean,
I guess you should be allowed to make your own fuck ups in the slides.
There's an argument for that.
I that 18 year old girls going to suck that old man's Dick and she's going to
burn as hot as fuck up.
It's just like,
all right,
you want to do it?
Yeah.
She just wasn't into it.
She gave it a shot.
You'd like to old men.
She tried to do the old yeah,
just it's like daddy route.
But he's saying it's like at 16 you become a pretty much a woman.
Um,
I think you had an ac and you become a man.
Actually.
You are done re,
you know,
you're,
you've achieved your sexual readiness at six 16.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
Is that that should be the agent.
Yeah.
That's the age to where you,
nothing's going to change.
You're not going to,
well is the age is 16 in some states it's even 15 to some style.
Yeah.
Well,
this is one of the things that he talks about backing up a little bit more cause
it was really interesting,
just a wee bit while [inaudible] was a asking that question.
There's another part that he's talking about like a 35 year old banging.
Like if you're a 35 year old bang in a 16 year old
the world,
so men will apply to women as well,
but you don't find,
you don't think is it is cod the sick
25 30 year old guy to hook up with a 16 year old,
even though biologically it seems,
it seems like a common thing to do.
Yeah.
It's just sign it off.
I had the same thing.
Like I mean,
you know,
I'm just like the average guy.
Like my father is actually your preachers.
I was actually raised North Christian and I think conservative than most.
And um,
uh,
like I,
I noticed,
cause I,
at one time I was watching a play boys,
et cetera.
That is a new show.
And at one point a segment,
um,
they did research on their own viewers and they asked if he was at what age do
you find women the most attractive?
And the average answer was 16.
And I was like,
oh my gosh,
I had mentioned that their pen pals and then,
you know,
like,
uh,
a couple of years later,
well,
yeah,
two years ago I started making this documentary and then I finally figured out
why that was and why that makes sense.
I mean,
we are so programmed in Western society,
we are so programmed then,
you know,
everything under 18 is to bu,
but if you look at the world and you look at the age of consent,
you know,
it ranges from nine to 20.
Right?
So that's an 11 year difference at which people can say,
oh,
it's okay to have sex.
What country is the age of consent?
Nine years old.
Yemen.
Wow.
Nine country
age of consent.
You can't have which countries then?
Yes.
Wow.
I bet that what I want to hear what a weird world we live in and I understand
that.
It's like,
yeah.
You're said,
oh,
it's sick.
When you're attracted to a 17 year olds,
like it's not six it's everybody's body.
That's everybody.
Since we were told it's below 18 is sick.
Why?
Cause that's some 19 year olds will look super young.
Oh,
it's a 16 year olds who were on the cover of sports illustrated and I think 18
year old girls quite honestly are more mature than 18 year old boys.
Like generally speaking.
Oh yeah.
Quite a bit more.
Not just physically,
but mentally.
They usually like mentally more standup.
Used to have a joke about it.
But I was like,
where it's like,
oh,
they're not women.
He's like,
God disagrees.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Right.
You can have babies right away.
Yeah.
You can have babies at like 13 what the fuck is all about?
What are the imperfect little situation?
Another fuck up.
Yeah.
I guess that was for the days of when you want to go to 35 so I get on it.
Let's go.
Yeah,
maybe.
And I guess it was like days when we just hadn't done such a good job of
fighting off predators.
You know,
we're so good at fighting off predators were way better than anything else.
Oh,
they're so far removed from us.
Yeah.
I mean,
we're so good at it.
We don't,
we can't even fight them off.
Yeah,
we can just go outside.
You just separated.
Yeah.
We don't have to worry.
We're all fleshy and shit.
We're sitting in front of my house with shorts on and flip flops.
And by the way,
I live in a neighborhood where they've spotted mountain lions.
No,
they spot of mountain lions,
but it's so unlikely.
Yeah.
I,
my dog's here,
I'll tell you why I didn't want it onto that.
That mud ice and Alaska mud ice.
It's like,
I forget what body of water it was at.
The place we played was a bundled up against,
and so you just take a walk along this like it's mud freezes over and it just
traps boats in there and you can't like,
oh gosh,
it's totally frozen.
But we were there in like march or April and it was beginning to thought,
but it happened.
There was a sign says don't go onto the mud.
But I was like,
whatever.
Oh No.
Yeah.
And I walked out there like,
like 2030 yards.
Oh No,
the me just a big chunk of it just fell in.
Oh No.
And I was like,
Oh,
oh,
this is,
there's no rules here.
Like no one's here to protect me.
Yeah.
You could just die right here.
And it's like,
at this falls,
that's what's going to happen.
You're going to be stuck in this freezing cold water and you might not make it
out.
Were you thinking,
I don't know.
I would go out there.
Fuck this Indian guy was looking at me the whole time.
Yeah.
When you're a young man,
especially,
you know,
it was just staring at it and you're young period.
But especially young men,
young men do law.
Stupid Shit.
Yeah.
I had to walk like a round it and then come back in like it was like in my path
got enveloped by fall.
Why is it that young men are so much dumber?
The young girls?
Is it a testosterone thing?
Is it the testosterone comes in and just maybe come become this Dolby?
Yeah.
Nice.
It's like Mongoloid it's amazing that that's how it's person has made,
you know,
the testosterone is introduced into the system and then the,
the female becomes a mail.
People don't know that.
Like every baby baby fetus starts off as female and somewhere along the line in
the process it decides whether or not it's going to become male.
There's a reason why you have tits.
Dudes have tits because they started off as the that yeah,
get rid of them.
How crazy is that?
We started off as girls and they grew up with grew up penis.
Yeah.
We're like dumb big girls.
It's something that I dealt with.
Men are dumb,
big angry girls for money or all Monday.
I look,
I mean you can't,
you can't be a man and hate women cause he used to be one.
I mean literally all started off.
You had your heart broken
Amala
sort of d 12 songs.
I could see you eventually getting happy enough to settle down and have
children.
The problem is,
will you be able to do it?
Be gleaned where you get too old to have children.
Yeah.
Have just zero interest.
Then don't do it.
You don't have to do it.
You know?
That's one of the things that always really bothered me guy too.
But no children,
people would say,
oh,
you should have children and show children.
And I'd be like,
will you stop?
Like,
why are you telling you?
You know,
it would really bother me.
But what really bothers me about it is sort of the ignorance that people express
when they try to tell you what you should do with your life.
Because they tell you in a way like,
you're not living your life the right way to do this.
You don't know what to going on in my head.
You don't know what I'm enjoying right now or what my fucking overall life plan
is.
Don't tell me.
Assume that you know what's house for me.
It's growth.
So we were like,
well,
I don't want to be,
I just,
it's studies by the way that older fathers live longer.
Really?
Yeah.
And have kids that live longer.
Why?
Because you have,
you develop something inside you that you can pass on genetically that younger
parents cannot pass on.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Um,
well they worried about genetic,
like there's an idea,
not,
we shouldn't say they worry,
but there's an idea that things can be passed down genetically.
Even things like racism that,
um,
hmm.
Yeah.
Interesting.
There's,
there's a study,
there's a study that showed that children have,
you know,
really extreme racist parents,
even if they didn't have exposure to that parent had a tendency towards racism.
Wow.
Well,
the idea is that all of our is something's genetic.
Yeah.
The ideas are all very instincts.
So really some,
some form of information that we've stored as experience,
you know,
so like the discount,
either nature or nurture.
It's like,
absolutely.
Who knows,
right.
Who knows.
These guys named Rupert Sheldrake who does,
uh,
this,
he's,
I think he's an evolutionary biologist.
That's his,
uh,
his,
actual,
uh,
distinction.
But yeah,
he,
um,
does a sir,
uh,
a bunch of different tasks on different things.
Like it's called the,
uh,
the morphogenic field.
And the idea is like,
they,
they test things like to see if your dog knows when you're coming home and shit
like that.
And,
um,
apparently his,
his reasoning is,
it might be,
what's that?
Is that the old white guy?
He's an old,
old English guy.
Right?
It might be that all of us have ideas in our head that came like passed down
through generations in biology.
Like the Frat,
the fact that kids in New York City are afraid of monsters.
They're afraid of big cats in the dark,
you know,
they were failing.
It's because,
yeah,
exactly.
The idea is that that is somehow another,
a deep seated memories that existed.
Yeah.
That existed from w you know,
wolves eating people and most of probably not earlier on in our development.
It seems like that would stick longer than something that you get later.
Right?
If you relate it to like a human development,
like in one person,
well it's also,
if you're the most vulnerable,
what are you going to be afraid of physically when you're a child?
Everything is so raw.
So create a monster's man like almost instantaneously.
They're afraid of monsters.
Monsters,
not monsters in New York.
No monsters in New York.
They're not.
It's not based on personal experience.
It's based in something in their head.
Yeah,
it's going to eat me.
They worry about things eating them.
Kids have said that it's going to eat any of it too.
It's a weird thing when the kid says that too.
I'm worried a monster's going to eat me because in their world nothing needs
anything.
Yeah,
exactly.
Where the,
where the fuck are they saying anything gets eaten.
Yeah.
So his idea is not even be interested.
Somehow or another memories are transmitted through genetics and I think that
the idea is that as a really smart person,
you have earned the right to pass on some of that intelligence to your child.
So of your,
what makes you successful,
you're thinking irrational thing.
I mean I wonder if it's just something I notice or if it's something that's
real.
It's when you seen athletes,
children becoming athletes,
professionals.
Well that's physical genetics for sure.
And why wouldn't we go to the brain?
Yeah.
I don't think they quite understand what information is being transmitted.
I think it's still a lot of,
there's still a lot of guessing going.
This is why I think that's basic stuff though.
Difference between men and women where it's like if you take it to our muscles,
are muscular church shape differently?
Why can't our brains be shaped differently?
Not better or worse,
just differently?
Well we know that things change in the chemistry of the brain when testosterone
is introduced,
you know,
we know that,
that's something that happens and we know that men are better with three d
things were better with spacial differentiation's a measuring distances and
stuff.
But women are better at other things.
Like I,
you know,
like men have an advantage in games supposedly like geometrically and like pool.
Cause I've I've heard like said better.
Yeah,
I dunno how that the fuck you could ever prove that.
I don't know if at the top,
but I know that,
like I said,
the studies where the blind was better or worse at math and they said no,
no,
it's only cause they were introduced to and that's why they weren't taught as
well.
But then it's like,
wow,
now you're the one time when you really understand that human beings are,
there's no the man,
I used to always think that men were better than the women.
You know?
I just always think that women annoyed me.
So either they were cool or they annoyed me.
It was like there was,
there was very few.
You just don't noticing the stuff that the men do that annoys you as much.
Yeah.
It doesn't mean there wasn't a bunch of cool girls and I knew,
I certainly knew some cool people,
but I didn't realize until I had been around a mother and children and seeing a
woman have a baby and see the,
the,
the what,
what goes on and raising a child.
Then you sort of understand how we have to be different.
Then it sort of puts it all,
puts it all into perspective for you.
Like this thing is you become so self centered in your life and thinking that
your way of getting through this thing is,
you know,
it's like that's what's important and what's important.
As you get your shit done and you do this and you do that,
and I want to watch my show,
it's on eight o'clock and I want to let anybody interrupt me,
but alone every night.
Yeah,
let alone every night.
And that when you have a child that gets completely interrupted,
who stop living for herself in you,
you start,
you start living for yourself and for others it's,
it becomes a very different thing.
You still live for yourself.
You're still enjoying it yourself,
but you just have to move backwards.
You have to think about others.
It's like it's,
it's,
it's imminent.
It's important to huge.
It's everything.
It's true.
It's the source of all your happiness.
It becomes a,
a new type of happiness.
It's greater than all the happiness you've ever experienced before.
I was like heroin addiction a little bit,
but it's a little person.
You can talk to them and you can have the opportunity to raise good people.
It's a weird experience and I don't think everybody should have to do it.
Just like I don't think everybody should be a fucking vegetarian.
And I,
you know,
vegetarians aren't as ruthless about it as vegans are,
but the push on,
they assume that everyone has to be a certain way.
You're like,
shut up now.
He makes me want to not like that.
By the way,
the dubious science behind the,
the,
the fact that it's a nutritional equal.
I don't,
I don't agree that it is,
you know,
I don't think it's nutritionally equal.
I think you meant absolutely can be very healthy on an all vegan diet.
I absolutely believe it.
I know people who do it,
but I think there's a biological advantage to eating some animal protein.
I just do.
I,
I've,
I've tried it.
I've experienced with a bunch of different ways.
I don't find very many top athletes I know of Mac Danzig and I know of a few
others that are actually vegans that are participate in high level a athletics.
And Mac is a fucking specimen and a half,
but in today's days with,
you know,
really balanced protein powders that are a vegetable based,
you can do pretty fucking good on a,
on a Vegan Diet.
Yeah,
too.
Yeah.
I mean,
he's a look,
he's not abusing his body,
that's for fuck sure.
The guy eats super healthy,
he's shredded,
he's in great shape.
But I think that um,
if you,
it's a moral issue with him,
I think physically,
you probably still have to argue with that when people bring that up,
that's what everybody or whatever,
or I'm better than chicken,
but it's like,
yeah,
you know,
you're a little wrong.
You are better than a chicken,
but we shouldn't have to,
you know,
I would rather pay extra few dollars for chicken if I knew that it was just a
chicken that was hanging out,
living in a field or it's taking too long with no beak.
Yeah.
And born stuffed into a cage and stuffed with fucking hormones so that it's five
times the size of a normal check in that can't even walk.
Right.
Actually,
I heard that's not hormones and do that.
It's just selective breeding.
So I should correct myself there.
Cause I said that once and some guy who was a actually a specialist contacted me
and explained to me the whole process.
It's pretty fascinating.
Yeah.
So it's more selective breeding than anything.
And the only time they give him a hormones is when they got something wrong with
them leased out.
So this guy said,
but that could vary also from farm to farm.
And you know,
what type of chickens are they growing and shit and,
but you ever,
uh,
you know when you ever go by like one of those places,
it's like a chicken factory chicken factory.
Now it's crazy,
dude.
I saw,
I worked in a chip in a Turkey coop in Israel,
but they were,
they were just all on top of each other.
Lights are out when they,
when they unload them so they can't really see anything and they're just stuck
on top of each other walk.
They can walk around.
But they're,
they're,
I mean,
they're all over each other.
Fuck what a crazy existence humans are.
So,
you know,
once agriculture came along,
once we figured out the way that we could store things and we could start
growing things,
we don't have to move everywhere.
Let's just make houses,
you know,
we can keep the wolves away if we have these big ass houses.
You know,
once,
once they started figuring out how to do that,
boy that was a dark day for animals.
That was a dark day for cattle and fucking turkeys and chickens and anything
else we could corral up.
Wow.
That's,
I wonder if like the animal kingdom like recognizes that and it was just like a
few thousand years ago were all the animals are free and Roman [inaudible] and
one day these mother fuckers to start shackling us into cages.
How many thousands of years ago have we been doing that to animals?
Just like let's save this one for later.
But it's the only way to do it.
To have them all first and then like try to save those and we're like,
oh that didn't work this way.
I don't mean it's the only way to do it.
As far as I'm torturing the animals and animal cruelty,
that's not what I mean.
I mean,
you can't have him a wandering free and then go get them when you need them.
If you're going to,
you know,
if you're going to satisfy cities,
you know you have to have a very large volume output places.
Not saying that they have to be inhumane,
of course they can be humane.
It's,
it just would be much more expensive,
but you're going to need farms.
You can't just have wild animals.
It's just too hard to feed.
How do you want a million people mean?
I guess.
Yeah,
at the end of the day,
but that was way smaller.
Yeah,
way smaller.
If we had to like if we let all the cows free and we had to just go,
go hunt them down when we needed food and we ended up every animal,
the tone,
Jesus Christ.
That's all comes down to convenience.
It all comes down to convenience.
We cannot,
we cannot,
we cannot go and actually hunter,
I've got too much to do.
Yeah,
it's too hard to hunt.
So the only other,
the only other solution is to do a vegetable,
vegetable based diet,
a vegetarian based or Vegan based diet.
That's the only other alternative.
I mean,
otherwise you're going to,
you're going to have to accept the fact that some of your meat,
you know,
unless you're like really clean about your eating or you're one of those
Steve Rinella,
Dude's who goes hunting twice a year and,
and it comes back with a fucking Mousse and you just eat that until her exactly
like spring and then you salt it now freeze it.
They have like a freezer wrap and the deep freeze.
Those motherfuckers,
yeah.
Curtis coming to visit.
He just got up and he was like,
what do I eat?
What am I supposed to eat?
Why do I go?
What am I supposed to eat and I need,
what?
What's his name?
Who is it?
Kurt Metzger.
Oh,
I know Kurt.
Yeah.
He's like,
I thought you said Curtis.
I need pot.
What is,
what is in your fridge that's going to make me feel good and what's not?
You shouldn't even talk about this on the air.
And Dude,
I was,
that guy doesn't have a license.
He doesn't live here.
Careful the walls have ears chefy or what someone else.
No,
it shouldn't.
You know,
after all you've been through your,
yeah,
I'll throw all your people have been through.
You still trust the man?
Um,
yeah.
I don't,
I guess I don't worry about it.
It's going to come back at some point,
but I just don't worry about it.
You worry.
Yeah.
Don't giant smoke session after a show in San Francisco.
By the way,
we're willing everyone with this prescriptions only.
It has to be,
I'm assuming everyone there will have their prescription.
Um,
so yeah,
after the shows,
so this is a story I was talking about.
The guy's name is Terry Jones and he's the Koran building.
He's the Quran burning pastor from Florida.
Remember that?
Dual maker?
Yeah,
just this troublemaker.
Why are you looking for attention?
The dove world outreach center in Gainesville,
Florida has a hanged and effigy that has hanged.
They have hanged in effigy of President Barack Obama from the gallows on the
front lawn and as a sign that says Obama is killing America.
This is fucking crazy.
There's a sign on the back of uh,
the Obama trailer,
like a trailer behind them.
It says Obama's Obama is killing America and he's hanging,
man.
You know what?
I saw one of the airports I want to tell us,
it says,
how do these tee shirts with George Bushes picture saying miss me yet.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And 2013,
the end of an error.
That's what it was.
Individually.
I've seen that on bumper sticker and it's like,
oh,
there's a lot of people are like,
yeah,
how much racism is involved in this hatred of Obama?
Definitely some definitely some definitely some.
Yeah,
I agree.
I think it's blown out of proportion and it makes the non racist who just don't
agree with policy feel really scared and really shitty all the time to have to
worry about it.
Like I just don't think economically that's the policy instead of this other
policy.
But they have to feel like they can't criticize.
Yeah.
That falling.
I'm going to be called.
I don't want that.
I want to be called a racist.
I kind of held out hope that,
I mean I didn't really blame him for the bail outs cause I didn't understand it.
I on amazing things.
But the real problem is the NDA,
the national defense authorization act that treats the United States is a
battleground,
allows the military to fucking go in and intervene and us streets and arrest
civilians if,
what case?
Or was it just not ever,
for whatever reason,
they decide for whatever.
They just got all power
over to the military.
Exactly.
This is something that should have never been done.
There's no reason to do it.
It's fucking rigid.
Why would he do that?
Knowing what not to do that because it's the people that put them in office
wanting me to do that on a sign over all power.
The idea is that in,
in the event of something fucked up that goes down a terrorist attack on
American soil,
especially a big one,
a nuke,
something along those lines on the president,
they can control the situation,
begin to control the situation.
They can,
um,
go in and the military can arrest people.
I mean,
what you don't have the crazy idea is that the military can arrest people.
The military is people.
Okay.
They're us.
Then it's a volunteer army got damaged because people wanted a fucking job and
the idea that they can go around and arrest like their neighbors and shit,
they might have to do that.
I get,
I bet a lot of people are not going to do it.
You're going to have some red dawn motherfuckers going on in Syria.
The drafting people from those countries and make cities and making a fire and
the neighbors.
Yeah.
That's not gonna fly in America.
There's one thing that if we do one thing that we don't want to do,
we don't want to kill Americans.
Yeah.
Okay.
Start to be devils out.
It really did that for the other way.
It's like,
what good would this be?
What would this,
if it's abused,
I mean,
how could this be good?
Well,
the idea is that it can be good in that they can,
they would have the manpower to control a situation.
And if it's riding on the streets,
you'd want to be able to attain those people.
Well,
they're also extrapolating from what's going on or what started out with
operation or excuse me,
occupy Wall Street and seeing these massive protests where this big buildup and
this big,
the use of social media is people to organize a numbers has never been before
possible.
And they have an ethic together and they have an idea together and they could
get together and Mike Check Mike check and they chant and everybody gets,
that's scary shit to people that are in power.
When you're got a bunch of people standing outside where you do business every
day,
you're in the business of fucking people over and removing rights and,
and,
and so patients that have got you in into power and that's what you're doing and
that's your job every day.
And out there on the fucking street is a bunch of people who are calling you out
on your bullshit every day.
There's screaming out what you've done in Nicaragua and Panama.
Yeah.
What you were trying to do to America and what you've done that you know,
on and on and on and on and on.
Everything in the United States has ever done wrong over the history of the 200
plus years.
It was still alive,
has been shouted out of these people,
you know,
from the lawns all across the country.
And these people that have power,
they're like,
well this is what I have.
I can't punch you.
I'm going to,
I have,
well,
they also,
they realize that something could be coming in.
You gotta be,
you gotta be prepared.
And the best way to be prepared is what the military,
it's not with,
you know,
using the coast guard or you know,
using,
uh,
police like they did in the Chicago riots or anything along those lines.
We would rather,
you know,
they would rather just bring in the fucking marines and just boom,
biggest power we have.
Just go for it.
Look what happened at Kent State,
but a lot of people have short memories and Kent State,
they had a antiwar protest and Nixon's sick the fucking national guard on on
American students.
Wow.
They got shot and killed on TV,
you know,
I mean at all.
I mean,
there's video of him.
That's a problem if you're trusting just from regular due to not start some 19
year old who is trained.
Exactly.
Well,
not only that,
someone has told that regular due to shoot the 19 yeah,
he's told,
they've told them to take action.
And by the way,
you're giving guns to people and and sending them against other people there.
You always run the possibility.
I mean,
if even if it's us against us,
run the possibility sewing pulled the fucking trigger.
You know,
it's a strange situation to be in your marching towards someone with a deadly
weapon,
a weapon that kills you.
That's a fucking,
anytime you do that,
it's not safe.
Anytime you do that,
anything can happen.
You're sending the national garden and there's a bunch of students in the
national guard has guns on them.
Anything can happen.
Man.
Topic.
I don't think I should stop.
I think it was a runaway shaky.
Get crazy.
Someone could throw a rock at you and hit you in the head and then you fucking
shoot them.
And then the next thing you know,
all my God,
it's on.
It's on.
I mean that it could becomes a war.
Your daughter could get shot.
Get shot.
I don't know.
Let's find out a couple of old ones with school there.
Really?
Yeah.
Does he feel responsible?
Put proactively?
Yeah,
I think he should.
He's the opposite of Kent State Guide.
You think after mine.
Don't broadcast channel down guys.
Right for you Wednesdays.
Oh my God.
How many people?
Holy Shit.
You're telling me wasn't seven.
No.
Listen to this man.
They fired 67 rounds over a period of 13 seconds.
Killing for students and wounding nine others,
one of whom suffered permanent paralysis.
Holy Shit Man.
Oh,
67 fucking bullets,
man.
How many people shot?
Um,
total kid?
Four were killed and nine others were wounded.
Man.
Jesus Christ.
That's scary.
They just didn't,
were killed.
They were just taking be blowout about home,
about home.
It's Chris.
Where did shooting them,
man shooting them in a protest.
They were protesting ends.
The American invasion in Cambodia,
which President Richard Nixon announced in a television address on April 30th
other students who were shot had been working nearby or we're observing,
we're just protests.
Yup.
Other students were just observing the protest for a distance and they got shot.
He's got shot into a crowd.
Kids were standing outside.
They weren't even protesting like what's going on?
Boom.
They get hit what they call it,
doing anything.
Their college or Kent State.
They're not like stopping at the airport.
Well,
from like letting them go to Cambodia.
Yeah.
Like what do you mean?
Like why would that be B?
Why would they even worry about the protests?
Uh,
4 million or the TV,
by the way,
4 million students boycotted school all over the country after that.
Yeah.
There was a strike of a 4 million students.
They wouldn't go to jail.
They wouldn't go to schools.
High schools and colleges and universities close throughout the United States.
That was early television due to a student's track,
a 4 million students,
while they had to organize that,
how it,
how the fuck did they organize that?
4 million students had to do that with carrier pigeon back then.
How did they do it?
Wow.
That's,
that's how creepy our government was.
Just back then.
It was
so embarrassed.
I'm like,
look at all these students are on TV.
Like,
Oh boy,
we got to stop.
This is embarrassing.
That's so scary.
So scary that that happened.
Nixon was a scary motherfucker.
Dude.
You know,
there's a book coming out.
It says he's gay.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Nixon gay lover,
which him let him everywhere.
The other professional football player came out of the closet.
Really?
Yup.
Every once in a while you get these professionals that come out,
they just can't do it and you're like,
oh,
they don't exist.
It's just not accessible.
UFC,
there's gotta be a gay one.
Oh yeah.
Well,
there was one dude who was on the reality show that had done a little gay porn.
Oh yeah.
But he said that he was straight.
Was Nixon gay?
No,
but that doesn't stop the rumor mill.
I don't,
this ain't no,
he's not gay.
But the guy wrote a book on it.
And as long as you write that shit on paper,
it's real.
If it's fun for him to be gay,
guess what?
He's gay.
I don't care.
This study,
these are all these scientific things to get this proven,
you know,
because sort of givens for awhile.
Then they get this proven,
people still quote them in their original context because scientists just don't
get,
but it's been turned over or it gets stuck in their brain.
Like what?
Give me an example.
Um,
I'm trying,
I'm trying to think.
This wouldn't be an example,
something that happened,
but like,
let's just say,
uh,
the theory of relativity.
Has that been disproven?
No.
Um,
no.
I think it's been proven.
Oh,
really?
Yeah.
Um,
I don't know enough about it to explain it,
but,
no,
I don't,
I don't believe it's been disproven.
The idea is that,
okay,
how about your fast and the speed of light?
It's never been proven than anything was faster than the speed of light.
They had a subatomic particles travel faster than the speed of light,
but they believe that it was an error in the data.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Then there's a lot of speculation on that.
I don't know.
Someone's criminal intention.
We discovered from his brain a little bit bad because it was so,
it's proven so long ago,
so obviously hilarious now,
but she didn't,
after that years after it would be disproven.
They're like,
yeah,
but I still,
people would still,
scientists would still sort of quote that it like that.
He's got a big brain.
The real problem with like observing criminal intent.
Like what if you scan a guy's brain and go with the guy's got a criminal's
brain.
Well what if he has morals and he leave?
We have criminal thoughts,
but he doesn't do it.
Every time he sees a guy,
he's like,
oh,
what does that mean?
Quotable this fucker and take a shit?
But he doesn't actually do anything.
Yeah,
exactly.
What if he sees a girl?
I'm like,
fuck the shit,
but he doesn't do anything.
And he goes home and he's a good guy and he just fucking lines his business.
You know those are the gym works at a stress.
How about that?
How about people that have criminal brains that can function,
they can figure their way through life.
People just shoplift once in a while.
Like Richard Nixon had dirty birdie.
Hmm.
Well,
yeah,
it seems like water.
Nixon's darkest secrets.
The inside story of America's most troubled president.
That's what I'm saying.
Saying these gang.
Really?
Yup.
He had a gay affair with Charles Bay Bay.
The Bozo a key Biscayne Florida banker.
I could 1000% so that any president was be gay.
Of course he could be gay.
He was so who would it surprise me more?
Uh,
uh,
if Clinton was gay or if Obama was gay.
Oh,
Clinton.
No question.
Right.
So that can see Obama.
You could seal all being good.
Yeah,
I can see that.
I'm not saying that he's gay,
but it wouldn't be like,
well,
there's still go,
what like that.
So a lot of people that love to support Obama because he's black,
you know,
that's the other part of it.
Whenever I see anything about Obama,
if I say anything bad about a violin anyway,
I get a lot of black people to get mad at me on Twitter.
Yeah.
They'll say you're,
you know that it's racist or something.
Cause sometimes we just laugh.
It's true,
right?
Yeah.
It's funny you can't,
you can't say anything bad about him.
I had to pay more.
I always got shit from that.
Yeah.
It's funny,
right?
Yeah.
If you say anything bad about Obama,
you're racing.
I just pay more insurance.
It's this,
this surgery,
it's going to cost me like $800 instead of nothing.
Good because of Obamacare.
They're putting in their plant.
Really?
How did,
how did it affect you that way?
Well,
that because they had to hire two more people or whatever it is.
They only covered 90% of your stuff now instead of 100% with the copays,
we just paid less insurance to everybody.
But this is,
you have your own personal private insurance,
correct.
Through sac two.
Sac.
Yeah.
Okay.
And then you have a copay that became much larger.
Yeah.
They only,
instead of having a copay and then peg 100% of it,
they do the copay and then pay 90% of it.
You know,
Jacob Volkman,
the UFC fighter,
who's the one who said he wanted to fight Obama,
like he's a chiropractor.
He said Obamacare is completely fucking up his business.
They visited them,
the ca visited him.
Really the secret service rather.
Well,
I think he actually cost him like one of his jobs.
Uh,
a coach.
The secret.
I shouldn't say that cause I'm not exactly sure if that's true.
Yes,
I believe they did.
They had a conversation with him.
He's just,
he just won.
It was trying to talk shit after the,
um,
after the fight,
you know?
And then again,
he was in another post fight interview.
I was interviewing him and he made a joke about Obama.
Yeah,
yeah.
And uh,
it was,
I don't remember the joke.
People follow and hate him blindly.
Obama.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's true.
I think you're right.
He's definitely inspired a lot of,
a lot of energy.
I feel a lot of feelings.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
I don't know what it's like to be president,
but I do know that someone was,
I forgot who it was,
was referencing,
I think it was Penn Jillette was talking to about a alpha.
I might not have been pendulum starting my al Franco,
even people randomly,
randomly.
Um,
and then he was saying that,
uh,
you know,
Al Franken is a politician now and just talking about how difficult it is to get
anything done and it's incredibly difficult to get anything done.
And a lot of times when people think it's like,
you know,
this big,
uh,
big mad conspiracy,
it's really just the fucking club stalker story.
It's just bureaucracy in general.
But it is one of those in the Simpsons where they haven't tried to get them all
off those Springfield before,
uh,
fucking something hits on a comment,
hits them and they were like,
oh,
okay,
here's the bill to get everyone out of Springfield.
So then all die.
And somebody like,
oh,
I say we attach a free gay porn that bill.
And then I was like,
nope.
Rejected.
And it's over.
I think they have to um,
uh,
change everything over to the Internet,
including boxing scoring.
Did she did Manny Pacquiao,
fight,
fight.
Holy Shit.
That was a bad decision.
How was the fight?
It was a good fight.
The good fight.
Manny judges had it to,
judges had it to that Bradley guy who fought a good fight and he hurt his foot
um,
early in the fight too,
so that,
that perhaps that guy,
he might have broke his foot.
He like stepped over funny on his foot and cracked his toes and he was fucked up
after that.
But he still kept boxing on it.
Like,
like it was fine.
It was all my interest in boxing.
Well,
any last bit of it,
Manny Pacquiao completely out struck this guy.
I mean it was no doubt about it.
You look at the comp box scores,
he was swinging wildly and not connecting shit.
That's what that rep is.
That a [inaudible] was rough for boxing.
No,
the guys are good because a good raft,
but he's wrong.
Man.
He's just dead wrong man.
He was cracking that dude.
He wobbled him a couple of times.
The guy never hit Manny clean once.
He never hit Manny clean ones where like Manny was rocked.
He got rocked a couple times.
He stumbled when he broke his foot.
He broke his foot because he got cracked before that.
Oh really?
Gun.
He got nailed.
He got nailed a few times,
man,
cleanly.
We went back to his corner with like those eyes.
Ugh.
Of a guy who got hit.
Manny Pacquiao is a bad motherfucker.
He touched that dude up.
He did knock them out though.
The guy is tough as shit.
Bradley is a tough,
tough motherfucker,
but the whole thing smells and then Bob Arum who's hilarious.
Bob Arum,
who was the promoter,
said,
I'm not going to do a rematch first I wanted an investigation.
That's what he said.
I demand an investigation.
Meanwhile,
he's me ever since both of them,
right?
Yeah.
I think he's the promoter,
but he's Manny Pacquiao is guy,
but I'm demanded an investigation.
Mandan investigation.
Probably not going to happen as fuck.
He just would be hung in the wink gave the judges the wind.
Come on baby.
You know how much this fucker rematch is going to be worth.
I mean,
you've got a guy who's just unstoppable guy like packy out and the way they beat
him as they fuck,
I'm out of it and then pack out vowels to come back and revenge.
I can't even into hands of the judges.
So he goes out there,
it just puts a painting or Bradley rises to the occasion and be fucking pen
Edgar's him and it comes back even stronger in the second fight.
Never takes away all doubt.
Who knows?
It's my last bit of boxing was that one fight,
but they both had an not lose and now it's done.
Yeah,
that was another case that is waiting too long.
It was a bad fight.
It was bad fight.
Just,
I mean it was a good fight,
but it was a bad decision.
Rather it was a bad thing for boxing.
The idea that you could box a guy up like that and tag them,
rock them.
I had him winning.
Fuck man.
I watched it.
I watched it twice.
I had them winning.
No,
I didn't.
I didn't want my line.
I didn't wash that twice.
What have I watched twice?
I watch something else twice.
It just happened.
Oh,
camp Ellenberger.
I watch that toys a bumpkin fused and so at the Cha,
the triple he was,
he said so by watching hockey and I was like,
you didn't watch it.
Yeah,
I,
I thought I watched it twice but now I realize it hadn't.
But when I was watching it,
I remember thinking towards the end like yeah,
this guy might've won three rounds.
Wow.
Maybe,
you know,
some people had attended to pack out some people that had every round of pack
yell.
Sometimes I go back when I see a rough,
make a crazy call in any sport like that,
a hard boundary.
You currently go back,
you're like,
oh yeah,
look at that in slow motion and you realize how great refs are.
I should go back and watch it again.
Yeah.
Cause sometimes after with emotion changed,
I did watch that fucking fight between Ellenberger and Cameron again.
Did you see that?
God,
that was crazy.
Good fight.
It's crazy fight.
I can watch some of these in my hotel rooms.
Somebody,
I think it was the Adam Hunter and I hope it was at a month.
They said that that uh,
uh,
that Martin Kampmann comes from behind more than lance bass does.
I say,
I think it was Adam onto a job on her.
I'm pretty sure it was him.
If it's not,
please forgive me.
He's the one biggest one.
Tried it consistently and make jokes.
He's doing a lot of those now.
He's,
I think it's MMA roasted.
I think that's his,
um,
his thing.
His Twitter account.
Yeah.
But Dana thinks he's hilarious to triple is helping them write those.
Oh,
that's good man.
Yeah.
He knows a lot about MMA and he wrestled to the rest of them.
Coaches,
coaches,
kid.
Did he ever tell you he got in a fight with a friend of ours who will remain
nameless Marius,
and while they're in the fight,
the guy goes,
tonight we dine in Hell.
It's like in a fight with a guy and the guide says,
tonight we dine in Hell and rushes him.
The older guy said,
that guy's fighting with,
oh my God.
Oh,
hunter got in a fight with this guy.
By the way,
the guys that I liked,
the guy,
this is why I won't say his name.
I liked the other guy,
but
with these things,
I always think like,
just say it all the comics,
no cares.
No Way.
Rarely,
no,
I love the dude.
I'm not going to,
he got drunk.
Nope.
Can do it.
You know a lot
of those,
it's just a lot of dudes out there that don't take too well to be made fun,
unfortunately.
Yeah.
My Brian,
if any comments listening to this,
you're always able to quote me on anything.
Brilliant.
Just go for it.
Although by the consequences,
I love it out there.
Live in chef here.
Are you excited about this?
A Wednesday night gig?
I'm super excited.
We bring in with you.
They have those guys in my lot to bring anybody.
I asked the one,
not one.
They did that to me.
Once I get it,
it's like they're like,
they think they're taking a chance on me.
A lot of times they don't even know how to promote.
They tried to make up stories.
I'm like,
just say the Joe Rogan experience.
Say I cook it.
No one's coming for these other things you would making up.
Yeah.
You got to take over the whole night bro.
You got to take over the whole night.
Once you do this and you it,
it shows that it's successful when you saw a lot of tickets,
cause I know,
look it's just a matter of time.
They said they're already happy was ticket sales.
We can advance.
So I'll literally be even better after the show.
You're,
you're killing him dude.
You're out there killing them.
It's going to be awesome.
It's great for sure.
And then once the next time you go,
listen man,
let me bring my friends,
like agent sends it goes,
Oh yeah exactly.
I did it in Dallas with Justin Lin and Shawn,
but it was like we could do like death squad tours where we have like the main
shows with all of us on it and then we do fucking satellite branches two hours
away.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you are with Tripoli out in Sacramento and Joey.
It's with Josh McDermitt in San Jose.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you could do that and have shows like that all over the place.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's so much,
there's so many comedy fans out there.
So many.
It's because because of this you're able to find what your aesthetic would
naturally go to.
Yeah.
What's fun to listen to at work.
You know the type of people that talk shit about the things that you really care
what I mean?
Yeah.
But there's people in small towns that I've heard them say like,
I don't get to talk like that.
So like more than two people in my town or anybody try bringing shit up with
Bob.
The fucking guy runs a hardware store.
Who called the cops.
I'll think this ball.
I was on drugs.
I came over here talking to me about aunties and all this crazy shit and the
pineal gland.
Get the fuck out of here with that.
Had the stupid redneck accent.
It's always southern Neil plan tell you that,
man,
I don't know how to do a red neck.
That's not so,
but you know what they talk like that and like in like central Washington state
too.
Well not really.
You,
there's a little bit of a toying and there's the Michigan redneck.
It's a different kinds of fuckers.
Main redneck.
Those like,
yeah.
But the same like I believe,
I believe there's sunlight.
Everything's slow as fuck up there.
Deep freeze,
eight months out of the year.
Everybody isn't it?
Oh well I'm blend has common.
I told Margie a stack up.
Someone knows they daily logs taking a weird accent,
you know.
Do you know,
um,
my friend,
what the fuck was his name?
Bob Marley.
Do you know about my,
I've met him before.
I don't know if you don't know who Bob Marley.
Bob Marley is not the regular guy.
He's a stand up comedian from Maine and it's a,
he's a great guy.
I've known him since we were like open miker but Bob was like the comic in Maine
and their crushes in Maine
in Maine.
That motherfucker packs places.
He's like a huge,
huge star.
I mean,
he works everywhere.
I mean I've seen him at the,
on the list at the comedy works and uh,
in Denver and he works all the national clubs but,
but in Maine he was a god damn superstar.
He plays a city there every year like every,
and he'll just pack those in with so many big cities in America.
I listened to some of this stuff too.
He's got so much main joke,
so much main human I malarious that's what I said.
A lot of comics have jokes about coffee shops because that's what I do.
Other the writing,
just sit there and write all the time.
That's why we saw jokes about airplanes too cause
that's what you write about.
Isn't it weird how God can just like,
just fucking take,
I mean he's a hilarious comic.
I could see Bob taken off anywhere.
He's a really nice guy too.
He's like look,
an easy guy to load that thing I heard where he writes in new hour or close to
it.
Yeah,
I believe it.
He's a funny dude,
but it's just,
it's,
it's so weird that one state where he just talked to him.
They've never done it with any other comedian before.
It's not like,
oh yeah,
there was that other guy from Maine.
They used to tour the country.
Oh,
there's that guy from main news.
Count them.
Not really.
Not many,
man,
not man.
You're right.
Not many guys become like famous performing in Maine in any state.
Really?
Yeah.
It's real rare.
There's a few guys.
Larry Reed was a Chicago guy who was big [inaudible].
You'll have a couple of big guys sometimes.
I think Austin has a bunch of guys still to this day,
like Steve Sweeney,
if he does a show still to this day,
sales race is out on the weekends.
I'm really,
yeah,
he's been around forever.
He's awesome.
Still Hilarious,
but he's a little for a living now.
Usually he does ray,
he's been on a lot of radio shows.
He's does a morning radio,
but he does stand up to,
you know,
they can make enough money just doing a few gigs a week.
I always wonder what those guys do.
After a certain amount of time.
Big problem with those guys that you stay alive.
A lot of those guys get hit with taxes.
Uh,
because,
uh,
during the heyday of the 80s,
the lot of those dudes were getting paid in cash and cocaine.
What's the percentage of pay when you have,
when you got that and coke?
Nobody ever offered me the coke pay.
Nobody did.
No.
To me it was always just a rumor.
I'd heard about the coke pay,
but I'd never actually seen it.
And the trust itself and the coat,
they wouldn't think.
Yeah.
Nope.
Never,
never did it.
So I didn't,
I never,
never saw it.
But man,
there was stories.
There are stories of guys getting completely paid in coke.
How do you want it?
You know,
they'd ask you how you want it.
You want in coke?
They're like,
what?
Give it to you and go,
I couldn't believe the first time the club owner was like,
Hey,
do you want me?
It's just like a future money.
It was like,
I'm gonna pay you off the books.
And I was like,
Oh yes,
you kidding me?
Wow.
They can do that.
How can they do that?
It's like petty cash or something.
Wasn't it enough to like really worn it.
It was only 500 bucks and when he does that disease I make an extra one 50 why
don't have to pay just like that?
Yeah.
She was like,
fuck you up.
You're saying it on the Internet.
I'll say the exact club catch a rising star Vegas.
It wasn't that.
I think they're out of business.
It's actually perfect.
That's lasted.
You usually book catch what?
We used to go,
I made up capstone out of business.
The last stop in Houston was the fucking,
the best spot for that.
It was the same guy by the way.
Who did it as accused me of lying to him the next year I came back and they had
to put me on the phone cause they were like,
how much you get paid?
I'm like,
I told them how much it was like it's this much and then he goes and goes up.
They put me on the phone with,
because I don't believe it was no way you got paid that much.
I'm like,
I got paid this much last year.
And he goes,
you're a liar.
You're lying to me one.
I was like,
all right.
I'm like,
Rogan will pay me either way.
When I got home,
I don't care.
Oh yeah,
you were the choker.
He does.
Yeah.
That was dumb.
And they looked it up.
They saw,
they pay me the exact same amount last year.
No apology.
Wow.
For calling me a liar.
No,
Paul.
Not like,
Oh man,
you're right.
I,
you got to understand.
I've never paid though people,
people that much.
Why don't we weird?
Nothing.
He's just so used to dealing with assholes.
Or is he just an asshole?
Which one is it?
What?
What are you doing is,
oh,
he's trying to figure out.
It is.
I thought you were talking about next.
My thanks.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I can't tell you.
Yes.
Hi.
Um,
yeah,
he had a,
that guys had to answer.
Do you guys do around the issues?
He had issues with other people that I know as well.
Did you hear about that guy from,
from Tempe?
Yes.
We've been talking about that at all.
No,
we haven't.
We should talk about that.
Yeah,
yeah.
Go ahead.
Tell the story.
This guy on the Tempe Improv.
Yup.
Mark Anderson.
Um,
I'll,
I'll say his name because these facts don't matter anymore.
Not Anymore.
Um,
he only tap him for a long time.
Big Christian.
I believe he was one of the guys wouldn't let us drink on stage and we've said
it was like state law and you're like,
state law really doesn't make sense.
It's so funny what your later like,
oh,
okay.
It's the Christian thing.
You don't want me to drinking.
Staying up live came in the Improv.
People who won't stand up.
I've came in and said,
hey,
we're going to open up.
Do you want to go and visit with us?
He goes,
no,
I have a place ready.
And it goes,
okay,
well then we're going to open up and we're going to use all your stuff and he's
took the hard line and then stand up.
I took all their business and he was upset.
They share proprietary information,
which is pretty much just how much do you pay these comics?
Uh,
wrote this diatribe online saying we're shutting the Tempe Improv doors down as
of June 1st,
just 10 days ago.
Right.
Um,
and then promptly went missing
for three weeks until
what happened?
They found his body.
Where do they find it?
In a hotel room.
Yeah.
What happened to the definitely suicide when I,
when I said he was missing,
I was like,
that's a tough one more.
Oh,
we're both looking at each other a lot of mental problems.
He did.
Yeah.
He asks us a date.
He,
uh,
like I forget he's somebody's first day there isn't or something that he said
that he,
he assassinated JFK or something.
Oh yeah.
He had some mental issues earlier.
Wait a minute.
What?
But traumatic experience,
I don't know if was that,
but he had some mental issues earlier,
psychotic breaks or small psychotic breaks that he's recovered from,
but big emotional,
traumatic experience.
Send people into these depressive moments that,
I don't know,
I don't like something like that.
That was so crazy that it was like,
whoa.
Oh Man.
As soon as anyone missing.
I was like definite suicide before they found up dead.
I wasn't surprised at all.
The,
the new club essentially just came in and just open up a better club,
bigger anyway and more modern,
better cooler part of town a little bit.
And they said,
come into business with us.
We're opening up this new thing.
He said,
no.
Um,
so they got the other guy to come help them open when they fired him again,
I don't know.
It was just hilarious.
And then Dan Hill,
they're like,
come help us like gold.
Thanks for help by uh,
uh,
but they opened up this beautiful good 600 seats instead of the four fifths of
the,
of the club had,
well,
they probably just dealt with them and realizing he was fucking,
but it was these people from la live where people who own the Improv's,
right.
So they knew how much they were paying these comics.
So he's like,
you shouldn't have shared that with this new place.
Stand up live and look,
we're going to share it with ourselves.
And he goes,
that's how you were able to get these other acts cause you know how much they
were being paid.
But my theory is comics too.
You should all just tell each other how much you get paid.
I want you to be secret about it.
If they ask,
if you want to know how much to ask for some club,
let me know what's a jumping off ground.
Well you need a booking guy,
do all that shit.
Really,
you shouldn't have to deal with it yourself.
That process of wondering how much you getting paid and thinking about money
that takes away from the creative process,
but early on we were like,
how?
How much do you charge for this?
Yeah,
it's hard when you're doing it yourself.
Yeah.
You,
once
you develop a draw,
what you pretty much have now,
then you should start negotiating door deals and he started in Nicole say like,
I'll take 60% or more depending on the place and what it is.
And the said it,
one of the places they were like,
okay,
we'll offer you this much.
He goes,
no,
it's okay if you can give you 60% of the door,
but I have my own guy clicking in every single person that comes in and they go,
no,
we'll give you your original
cause.
Like,
well under those rules,
how can we call it the head count?
Everybody?
Yeah,
on the level there's no way.
Well there was a guy who was at the,
uh,
I don't want to say the club.
And he said,
yeah.
So kind of protecting these people who are just robbing comics.
He realized that there was more people in there.
Then the club owner was telling him and he had a door deal.
So he made everybody say a number one,
two,
three,
four,
all in once you said your number,
don't know what else.
Say a number and let's see how many people are here.
I think we could do this,
this will be fun.
So he did it as like a fun thing for the audience.
I mean I did the door,
it's like 500 he was like,
what the fuck are the 330 seat club?
He got,
this is like 500 plus people in there and he thought he got there.
I was like,
this is not 300 people.
Somebody got in trouble once for telling us how many seats there was like,
Oh,
I'm actually not supposed to other comics.
Like why would you not supposed to tell the comics?
Yeah,
how many seats there are and the comedy club.
Well someone told me you told it to me.
It's sort of malicious,
only about a certain club you know and has more seats here than they say,
yeah
I should be running this beef.
That was another thing and thing with it.
You were gonna get some big bonus.
You get a bonus for sell out sometimes,
but everyone has and like a specific amount of people as a bonus,
you get an extra 500 extra thousand dollar temping and would give you that.
Yeah.
But they said no bonus one time.
And then Tate was whether it goes,
wait,
I had these eight friends that showed up and you said they couldn't come in
because there were sold out and now he didn't get a bonus for selling out which
one is it?
We for away what?
What?
What was it exactly?
And then they're like,
oh yeah,
you're right.
That's a case I've heard a thousand times.
I'm not money.
But guys are like,
oh,
what about the bonus?
Like,
Oh yes.
Oh yeah,
we did a run.
That was back when that other dude was running it and he was crazy.
Yeah.
I don't know what was going on with that dude.
Don't do it.
Had issues.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Obviously,
you know,
and then,
that's why the Improv took him in and,
or the other Santa Clara took him in and then like,
get the fuck out.
But you think about it,
it's like,
what,
how would they benefit from stealing 500 bucks?
And you're like every week,
500 bucks to a club that might not be making as much money as you think.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's usually a guy,
it's usually just going to make an extra 25 grand a year by just saying they're
honest and telling the improv chain they did.
There's a few guys in our reputations for being a little sleazy with money and
not telling the truth about sell outs and stuff like that,
but the thing is you can't pay attention all that shit.
You can't.
You got to just get to the point.
We were selling so many tickets.
Every show is a sell out so you don't have to worry about it.
That's what they told me,
not in Philadelphia about youth specifically were like,
he won't raise the ticket price so we know exactly how many seats we have.
They will all be taken.
Then we can just say,
here's how much we're going to pay you.
There's no surprises there.
Yeah,
it's a good deal that Philadelphia places is awesome to,
helium is one of my favorite places to do and then it's a good place to go and
fuck around there.
Like Fun,
lighthearted people in a fun way.
They're rowdy,
the smart.
That's a good place to go.
But yeah,
that's uh,
that's the way to do it.
I mean,
we've been doing it for so long that way where we just go and take over a place.
You kind of forget that this is not the way most places,
most places have their local guys.
That week is different week.
Yeah.
I was begging this guy last time I was there to take his girlfriend to go to the
bathroom to go fucker.
Whoa.
She wanted to so bad and was like,
we can,
she was like all over him drunk.
Just all,
it just kept kissing his neck in the front row.
I think I'll just go,
oh no,
you can't just take our crowd.
Why not just people.
Are People going to go jack off by the door or something?
Rose Man.
Do you imagine that they actually just get hung up and run out and actually go
somewhere and everybody cheered him on?
That'd be great.
He'd probably make the Huffington Post.
Oh,
that'd be nice.
The Huffington post.
That sounds true.
When they arrested you for participating in sex act,
you were the administrator or director of a subject.
I'll be like with new monitor.
Lenny,
Bruce,
Fran,
San Fran.
He can get away with it.
Oh yeah.
They have a lot of sex acts that they have sex acts there.
Yeah.
You can go and watch like girls jam dildos in themselves.
True Fest Is July 21st 20 seconds.
We went down.
This place wants me and Brian shroom fast.
Yeah.
Oh No.
I went to one of those took off places.
Oh,
and shrimp fest by the way,
is taking place while you and I are in Calgary.
Right?
Well,
they're not that type of perform.
not be for sure.
I'm first starting at midnight after we perform,
so the 21st it starts 21st 21st 22nd and 23rd that's what it is,
but by all means,
if you were to take mushrooms before the show and just think it would continue
until after midnight,
that would totally count in my book.
I got this new bit on the nature of reality.
That might be a little too slippery.
If you come to the show on mushrooms.
I'm just going to really,
La Library Library.
Yeah.
Get yourself now,
celebrate all over the world.
Be a part of showing first,
I'll tell you what it is now a good movie,
but from atheist you didn't like it said it's like a soap opera,
like a girl,
a chick flick.
Saifai well a lot of people got mad at me so you don't understand it and this
and that.
There's,
there's a bunch of cut the shit scenes in that movie that I won't,
I won't.
Oilers [inaudible] a movie for me.
I really wanted to watch this movie.
I looked forward to it.
I was joking around that everyday was downtime to permeate came out.
I went on a double date with Mrs Rogan and her sister.
We had a great fucking time all night.
Went to that stupid movie and like just
really what happened.
Talk to me about the movie comes out cause they're all still so jack number,
star wars one.
And that came out,
I've already for a week or two.
It was like that was awesome until it slowly started to seep into their,
Brian's like,
no,
that was dog shit.
Star wars one was dog shit or whatever.
The new one came out 10 years ago.
Jesus Christ.
Thought you were talking about when star wars came out.
Oh,
by the way,
don't look at star wars again.
Oh,
it looks terrible.
No,
watch it.
Yeah,
it's terrible now,
but we horny acting weird.
A different Arab row.
It's a completely different era.
But yeah,
those doors came out and it took two weeks before we were all like,
oh yeah,
I didn't like the new star wars when then whatever it was the kid trying to be
like Yoda with the our banks and all that shit was light lightsaber right.
Wasn't that awesome?
That was Sorta,
it was wag.
So permit the same way.
I think people are still trying to fuck.
I looked forward to this movie,
but there was so many scenes and then we like,
wait,
come.
What the fuck?
What are you doing?
You dirty rat?
Yeah.
It takes you out of it.
I don't want to say anything because I don't want to give away any spoilers,
but I,
I wanted a light to it takes you out of it.
That's why waiting to talk about it.
Sorry,
I can't wait until everybody's seen it so we can dog them.
If you got like a month and you can just go after a month,
I can talk about it.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's enough of a spoiler time.
Brian,
does that sound right?
How long would you say?
Not Years.
I don't know.
I'm just want to talk about karate right now.
You can talk about the end of karate kid.
You just got to say,
spoiler,
and then say it.
So listen folks,
this is a spoiler.
Spoiler,
spoiler.
Well,
don't tell him no.
Yeah,
but next time when you do it,
next time in a month,
I'm going to give it a month.
I got,
I like it.
It could have been great,
man.
It had some potential visually.
It's fucking stunning,
man.
I want the coupled with a great story.
I think it's really hard to make a big budget movie and not have it be dog shit.
I think it's really hard.
I think you fight so many different people.
Some just wanting to,
nitric wanting to,
or Greg.
Yeah.
Hmm.
I wonder,
I wonder what happened,
but how bad was matrix three?
Right.
Kind of ruined the whole thing for you,
right?
It's like,
what happened here?
What did you guys do?
Did you just throw this one together?
It's so bad.
Some weird Jesus correlation thing that was going on.
He didn't quite get what by the way,
there's a Jesus correlation thing going on in this movie as well.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Are a lot of people missed?
It's very baffling.
I,
there's a,
there's like interviews with Ridley Scott about the hidden symbols,
symbolism in the movie and what it really means of this movie.
Yeah.
What's the,
what's the subtext?
Okay.
My feelings is you could have hidden symbolism if you want,
but the main text has to be true.
Yeah.
When you see a tanty no movie,
he might be saying shit about relationships and the power of one man opened up,
but making it bad ass action scene and you know,
here's another part is a CGI works great for monsters,
but they haven't quite got it together.
For people.
For humans.
They just have cartoonish.
Whenever they fly in job or wave their arms,
it looks like there was stretched out.
The movements are there.
They're not real weird.
It's weird.
Spiderman,
that's,
we weren't Spiderman for me,
like um,
land of uh,
no,
not land.
The lost the fuck is walks fucking I am legend.
Oh yeah,
I am legend.
Those things there were obviously fake.
Yeah.
We kinda cool looking cool.
Looking from carrying the club.
We like,
come on man,
that's fake as fuck.
But I was willing to,
I was willing to accept that for the fun of the movie.
It was a great movie.
It was way better movie than this movie.
I am
legend.
I am.
Legend was a pretty fucking sporty movie.
It was a lot better than,
in my opinion.
It just didn't leave me with so much behind at the end of it where I was like,
you got it.
You hope that girl makes it to where she's gone.
Why
legend?
But you're like,
but I get it.
You know,
it was cool.
He was a man living alone for a while.
Once you get to see a little bit.
It was great.
Yeah.
He was an awesome actor too.
He did a great job in that movie.
He's pretty much couldn't do anything right now.
Yeah,
he's great.
When he was pretending to be going crazy,
you know,
because he wasn't talking to people.
Oh really?
Yeah,
and he was pretending he did a great job of it.
Oh yeah.
It was really good,
you know,
and the way he was protecting himself by hiding from these fucking things at
night and had everything rigged.
Oh yeah.
It was pretty bad ass,
man.
That was it.
That was a bad ass.
And you could only work during the day.
Yeah.
What's a good,
sorry?
Moving.
Yeah.
He'd go around the stores and take canned goods and shit and cook food and then
he would have to fuck him.
He's locked down at night and kind of bathtub.
Yeah.
What the fuck man,
that was like when he had to kill it.
Yeah.
There was like,
oh no,
there's only friend.
So bad ass fucking movie,
man.
That is a bad ass movie.
Yeah.
But the CGI sort of,
it gets to,
you know,
you're like,
okay I know I'm watching bullshit.
Yeah.
But the first two thirds of it,
when you didn't see any of those guys,
it was like fucking cool.
CGI is weird cause it's,
it'll work really good for like shit that's not real.
Like it works really good and call it monsters when they have the catsup
dripping of the parties that's dripping.
It's like,
yeah,
it looks like it's on purpose.
Falling like the too fast right away.
Then speed up at the right levels or something.
Son of bitches.
It looks right at first.
When you look closer,
how long before they've CGI support,
have they done that yet?
Well they had the,
not animated porn but you know the,
it's not that good luck.
No.
Have you ever beat off to that?
Scared.
It's a new frontier for me that I don't want to get into it.
You know what I mean?
And I may point you got caught watching cartoons.
You got jaw jerk off watching porn.
Like what's next?
Right.
So it opens up a door for you.
Yeah.
You start jerking off the cartoons,
you've got a problem.
It's pretty hot though.
Have you jerked off to it?
Probably you would have to jerk off to it.
You will get a boner and you would jerk off to it.
You know if he did or didn't I,
you know,
I'm sure I did when I was younger.
You sure you did when you were younger?
Back in cartoons are cuter.
Yeah,
like when like when I was like the classic keen or so because I mean they have
like hot shit like tentacles and like fucking what do you think life would be
like if TV was like the Internet?
What are you just getting free walk if you can get whatever you want on it first
things first,
no more accents.
No more accent would all go away.
You become the sameness.
Sameness.
Wow.
Really?
Because everyone would get everything together so everything would just go away.
There wouldn't be regions.
You wouldn't talk like this in the south.
If all you're watching is southern stuff in Canada,
right.
You will start talking like the south.
Everything would just meld together.
That's a theory,
right?
If everyone watched TV,
is that what he's saying?
But we have accents in America.
It's going to go away.
Really.
You think accents in America to go away.
They're all going to go away.
How are we going to fucking find a middle ground?
How long is this going to take?
It's going to generations.
Probably generations.
That'd be one.
Maybe two more cause you still have to talk about everyone around you and the
Internet and TV,
but soon it will be just as much internet TV,
like less and less.
People in the south will have accents and I will just lead to good geometric
rods and lab accent.
The tile and chicks have it.
I don't want them to lose that Shit,
man.
There's that and it's good movies,
especially cowboy movies.
I don't want to dude,
who doesn't have a fucking southern accent and a cowboy movie and that Bot to do
that.
If they're not to,
they'll do it.
Boston accents,
you get a girlfriend,
oh,
oh hey girl from Boston and Baltimore like having a conversation.
Baltimore in Wisconsin,
Girl.
Oh my God,
I did a 50 shades of gray.
I was just going to bring that up.
Oh my God.
It gets me so hot right me toe.
How am I?
God Can I shut up?
Gets me hot and musty.
You heard of that shades of gray.
It's a new thing.
It's a new twilight.
Apparently it's like bondage and shit and chicks get hot and then the the
handsomest man in the world,
Ryan Gosling is going to be,
it's not one he's going to be playing up there from shades of gray.
Played them the main guy.
Wow.
Starting off.
I don't know who the fuck it is.
I don't know that works.
What if that was one of their names?
John Shade and that's the name of the book.
You've dummy girls dumb,
but you know how much faith do you have in them after twilight?
Very,
very little.
Very little.
That's nonsense.
They were like,
it's so wonderful because true love beats everything and you're like,
are you do you don't want realism at all and your stuff?
Huh?
New,
but you know why he wants it made me laugh so hard and I thought about it for
years afterwards.
At the comedy store.
There's billboards.
It always gets sponsored by the same company and they'll change them and for
awhile,
whoever own lifetime by a calm had the one next to the house of Blues,
the billboard.
It was always lifetime shows and they were these cops.
He's like three chick cops with the holding guns up with dude.
Constant standing behind him and you were like,
lifetime is just Saifai for women.
It's just like,
what?
Well does this exist in three fucking tough and rumble cops?
The Charlie's angels like,
what are you talking about?
This is based on reality and she has time for a family.
We can do it ladies,
honey,
I'm getting my degree while I'm cooking breakfast,
going over papers.
I'm going to go get her woman.
That is,
it's real and it's like,
oh,
I love it.
If you would make love to a vampire,
he doesn't even have to die in the sun.
He just sparkles
this park on this time.
So beautiful.
Oh,
I think people can't trust themselves.
I think people need to be regulated.
When I think it is,
man,
this is what I'm thinking is I used to be judgmental like you are each sphere.
I say,
there it is.
I prefer the term
observant.
I like the Avengers,
Bro.
I know the Avengers is not real.
I think when the hawk grabs Loci or Lodi or whatever the fuck his name is,
smash,
smash them in the ground.
My Dick grew an inch and a half.
It's,
I know.
I got so excited.
I was like,
yes,
go get on the same thing,
but that violence,
real violence,
I can't even happen.
No,
there's no pause.
There's no hulk.
You watching some fake fucking whole puny God.
I love that shit.
It's fun.
It brings me back to the days when I was a teenager and I was collecting comic
books and I'd sit around with my friends would talk about,
you know,
the new issues and I fucking loved comic book.
Maybe that's why men react viscerally to twilight is because it was vampires and
werewolves.
That should be cool stuff.
She'll be amazing.
They fucked up vampires and werewolves,
so yeah,
we don't mind.
It's okay with the long hair,
blond guy,
fucking fuck sharrow whatever his name is.
What's his name?
Fabio.
He comes along
where wasn't vampires,
but isn't it fascinating that it would be then it would be this morphing of a
man and a woman together.
It's a man with beautiful hair.
It's like that's what they really want himself and walked.
So on a muscular version of themselves,
they want you to have the same aesthetic.
They want you to have beautiful hair.
Then that's why they love days.
They want to love,
they want you to love romance.
The way a woman loves romance,
it's a different need to be desired than the men have.
It's completely different.
It's amazing with men.
A lot of minutes.
Physical girls like,
can you take me out once forever?
And I'm like,
why would I,
what do you mean?
Where are we going?
Everything that's going on.
Yeah.
This is awesome.
What are you talking about?
Why can't change things?
Yeah.
It's um,
it's,
it's weird,
but what I've learned is that you just got to deal with the fact that they like
different shit.
It's not you.
You can get upset.
Like when I was a kid,
if you didn't like to kind of music that I liked,
we were probably going to get in a fucking argument.
You know what I mean?
Like if you'll look a other things though.
The who socks for the fucking who sucks.
Sucks you what?
How could you wait?
Well,
you see the who sucks.
It's not possible,
but it's,
some people just say the who sucks and to them it sucks.
I have friends who love the grateful dead.
I can't get into it.
I've tried.
I can't do it.
Here's where I'd just like rob women.
It's a sense of entitlement and a feeling of success that comes through.
No personal labor.
Okay?
Yes,
but
you're talking about idiots and those idiots could be women.
They can be Douche bag men.
They could be.
They just happen to be women.
You're talking about idiots.
There's a lot of cool chicks out there that there are there.
Are
they like all this shit?
It's not,
they're a damn vaginas.
It's a different setup.
I can't even imagine.
I don't understand it.
They like it.
There's,
there's shit that people fucking liked it I don't get.
And somewhere along the line I've learned how to let that go and not be excited
about it.
It doesn't,
it doesn't matter if you like something that I don't like.
But when I was growing up,
man,
it was super important when I was growing up I was stupid.
We want everyone to like where you like and you also want it to be something
that no one else liked.
You want to be different to sort of not really.
Yeah.
I was too insecure to be in anything obscure.
Oh I was,
yeah I was,
I would like hide my obscure taste and all the information society.
No,
I was really insecure and I liked like kiss and some things that a lot of people
didn't like cause it was like bad to like that,
you know,
if you,
if you like kiss in the 80s you were,
you were a loser.
Meatheads were at their strongest and the Eighties Jersey kind of like guns and
roses,
just dumb rock,
you know,
van Halen.
It's just like with the cool people then.
Yeah.
But that's,
you caught cut off.
He shows a meathead no,
but his fans,
the people that made up the metal lands when they watched the guns and roses
concert,
you would never want to hang out with them.
Yeah.
Maybe just cut off Ocean Pacific tee shirts with net with like re like,
oh yeah.
But there's something about being in the presence.
If I was a kid,
I have loved the opportunity just to be in the presence of a great band like
that.
How many great bands have you ever seen live?
Um,
not many.
I used to go to a lot of concerts,
believe it or not,
when I was a kid.
You know,
when I was in high school,
I got an in with a crowd of kids that,
uh,
we're really into going to concerts,
music festivals or music rather.
There's so much fun to watch.
And I started working at a concert place just so you could watch more.
No,
because it was a good job.
Um,
me and a bunch of the dudes from my taekwondo school worked at great woods,
so I got to see a lot of concerts.
I'd be like out there in the,
in the like,
uh,
like the,
the,
there's like a,
an outside area.
Part of it was covered and then has a long area in the back.
You got to watch him here.
Yeah,
I'd watch it from their listening from there.
I'd go in,
I could go in sometimes and hide.
I'm like,
you're going to watch the concert.
It was like a band I wanted to see or like I saw Cosby performed there.
I saw Kennison performed there,
saw Rodney Dangerfield.
Rodney Dean shows,
went on stage with a bathrobe on naked in the bathroom and he's just hanging
around backstage with his bathrobe on.
It would go on stage with his bathrobe button.
That's how you would do stats because he didn't give up the ultimate,
it was just like,
I've got this presence that people don't judge me.
I hear to use to smoke pot all the time.
Cops for gave him for it.
Rodney Dangerfield man,
he's brilliant.
And he would,
uh,
up.
Yeah,
he would be hanging out backstage is balls are hanging out and shit.
I didn't go backstage.
I didn't see him,
but they were telling me they're dudes.
We're calling the radio cracking up.
Rodney Dangerfield sat here,
balls,
ass naked as and nuts are hanging out and he's got a robot and he's about to go
rock 15,000 people.
There you have.
It was like,
why not just do it with your friends?
It's more fun that way.
He was like,
well I get dressed well I,
well,
yeah,
totally.
Well that's one of the reasons why I wanted to do with my friends cause I saw
Kennison there.
I saw Kennesaw and Greg Woods and he would do this,
uh,
the outlaws.
Wow.
I have one of these.
I have a poster from outlasts.
Oh,
that's cool.
Underneath the fridge.
It's hidden back there somewhere.
Oh,
that's really cool.
Yeah,
it does.
Outlaws.
You hear that stuff about them.
I'll party and go and do whatever they want and taking over a town for a little
bit.
It was just like,
wow.
Just seems interesting.
Wow.
Well they seem like they had a lot of fun to me.
What I liked about it is it seemed like,
you know,
like that's how you do it.
You do it as a group.
You know?
That was one of the reasons why when I started taking guys on the road with me,
you know,
at one point in time we got really big.
Like I remember we were taking a look,
a ton of people in the road [inaudible] me take Eddie,
you Diaz,
we would have shows like it's not even enough room in the van.
Yeah,
it was new.
We have to get cargo vans and shit.
Well,
when we trimmed down,
it was a little more manageable,
but it's just way,
it's way more fun.
It's way more fun to do it that way.
I remember the first time when I started going,
okay,
how bad was I when I,
when I started going on the road with them,
because I see sometimes like newer comics are like five year comments that are
proficient but so fucking shitty.
At the same time.
You had some really good jokes,
man,
mixed in with some jokes where you were just reaching a little,
but you figured it out.
You're a smart dude,
you will,
you,
uh,
you know,
you would analyze your material and you would try new shit and you would go
pretty far out there to try a bit.
And if it didn't work,
didn't work.
And now you know,
and start from scratch.
But you,
you had the most important things.
You had something,
you know,
you had something you could kill,
you could,
you could nail it.
I use words like,
I just use the awful segues there.
Just obvious.
And like you had to get comfortable.
It takes a while to get com.
It takes a while to really think about what you're actually doing to,
what are you doing?
Trying to introduce thoughts as cleanly and easily into people's heads and get
them to see your point of view on things while laughing.
And it has to be,
you know,
so you also have to understand yourself and how you come off to other people
too.
You know,
we can all come off kind of goofy and Douchey and so it's hard.
It's hard in that sense too.
You're,
you're just,
you're still insecure as a person,
you know,
you're coming into your adulthood,
your independence,
you're out there trying to make it as a comic at the same time and know dating.
So there's a lot of instability going on your emotions and everything is up.
Like it's in a toss and tumble world,
you know,
it's tricky.
It's a tricky thing to manage.
It's hard to be good as a comedian.
But you had potential,
you know,
you would,
you would always nail like it would be like one or two like big laughs.
Well,
I mean if your flight's getting laughs,
I feel like when I watched some of the guys will open for me and it's really in
that four to six year range.
Right?
It's like you know how to get laughs but it's just like they're obvious lines or
just sounds fake faking it a lot.
That's just because you have,
um,
you have high standards for yourself.
You have a good work ethic and you,
but you can't be great from the beginning.
No,
you know,
it's just,
it is what it is.
But I remember when people are telling you like,
that guy's bad man.
No.
Well there was certainly some people that didn't think that you will or Dhea
were funny and uh,
I thought they were idiots.
Like,
you know,
I don't have arguments with them,
but you know,
they would discuss writing and it's,
and I'm going to look,
I'm laughing so you're wrong.
You're wrong.
And you,
and I mean,
we had so many conversations about standup and about material and developing
material.
I knew it was just a matter of time for you to figure it out.
You just started getting stronger and stronger once you started doing like those
regular sets you got,
you got way better and like a couple of months,
just the first from the first time you started working with me to like a couple
months later when we had done a bunch of big rooms or going on the road,
that was,
that was one of those things that people said,
you don't want to work on the road because it'll make you bad comment.
But then when I had never done it,
it was like,
well,
I'm only in La Comic and then I went on the road.
Really within a couple of months I people would be like,
all right,
you just stepped up a level,
like,
why don't you just move up like that?
It does not make you a bad comic.
[inaudible] can help you develop bad tricks if that's all you do,
if that's your mode,
but it's not my mode.
That's never been.
My mode is always been what is what is interesting to me?
You know,
and then let me,
let me try to explain that interest.
Let me turn it around.
La and sitting in La crowd,
you get a hipper,
more developed sense of how I can relate to people.
You do until you develop your own crowd.
Our crowd is essentially the same crowd everywhere,
man.
We were talking about that Edmonton show that we did fucking awesome,
but it doesn't matter if you're in Edmonton or South Texas or Maine or wherever.
It's just these people that are into the same aesthetic.
Yes.
It's a bunch of likeminded folks that would be fucking supersite if aliens
landed or looking forward to seeing if GSP ever fights.
Anderson Silva probably high as fuck right now because not all the same,
but there's this range that they all fit into really similar.
We're,
we have a very specific crowd and it's the nicest fucking crowd.
One of the coolest things is when we perform places and they keep telling us
that like the people at the Ice House always say that because the Ice House is
nice people,
you know the owners are awesome.
Bob's awesome,
Sean's awesome that everybody works there is awesome.
They're just,
it's a real friendly environment.
So when they tell you you guys have the best crowds are so nice,
every one thing you always go,
I was always talk to the waitress,
especially renewing like two hours just sitting there.
I'd be like,
let's talk I guess,
but I was like,
how'd you do?
I'd always have to how they did tip wise and it was like,
it's amazing week.
It's an amazing week.
And if like Asian comics or sometimes like Middle Eastern comments would go on
those people in general.
The cheap don't.
Yeah,
so it's like fraught.
So there's like opposite extremes and you were the high end.
Wow.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
And even where I am or I only get,
like I said,
like 20% of the crowd,
whatever it is,
whatever percentage it is,
it's still like overall.
They're like,
no,
I did really well tip wise,
percentage wise on my tips this week.
That's awesome.
So I feel good.
I'm like,
those are employees you want to do well.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
it sounds Corny,
but we're all working together.
If you have asshole waitresses just to,
the crowd's going to feel shitty and they're not going to have fun.
Nice waitress is make for a friendly crowd.
But comics,
different comics bring different crowds,
man.
It's just a fact.
We used to work places and they would say,
fuck,
this asshole just came through last week and it's crowded full of fucking
idiots.
They would,
they'd be really mad at certain people,
you know.
You know what I realized?
Yeah,
exactly.
He was the worst man.
That fucking guy.
I always hear that.
Hey,
I mean think one.
He is a rude,
selfish person.
I don't think it's related to that.
You don't think that just cause I've heard about some other people who were
super nice people.
Right.
But the crowds are off whatever TV show they're on.
Oh,
you know,
I mean,
let's say you got a job and you would have taken it early on if it was just WWF
correspondent shit,
I might take that shit tomorrow,
but that would get a fan base.
That might not be polite comedy type of people.
Yeah.
It might not be,
you know,
but it would be no fault of your own.
Just some job.
They offered me a job in WWE and I had to wear like an outfit,
like a debate and a bottom,
and I did every show high as fuck.
That would be there.
It has to tell would be the,
uh,
the thing.
They would come to me,
I'd be in a lab concocting newer,
stronger marijuana that defies the test.
I'm screaming,
yelling,
I have tested negative again.
How's you to test?
Negative.
That'd be a whole new kind of villain and the WWE.
Yeah.
It doesn't have to wrestle any dudes.
I can be one of the outside guys.
I don't want to get thrown on my neck.
People don't realize how fucking hard that is on your body,
man.
That's fake.
Wrassling is super hard on your body through Piper's.
So toughened.
Oh yeah.
I'm sure.
It's like you don't have like old people's hands or like t his or her body's
like,
oh yeah,
we got that fake fight for,
for AAA shell.
You got to fake fight with Rowdy Roddy Piper.
Do you know?
Awesome.
That is so awesome to see it on TMZ later.
I was like,
just to say that you got to fight with Rowdy Roddy Piper.
It was so great.
I was crawling on my hands and knees.
The whole crowd was cheering Piper Piper.
It was so much fun.
He played my piano with my head.
It was so great.
I'm so happy I was there.
Oh yeah.
Damn.
I missed that.
Did you know we're about to do or did you just see me like stand up and say
something?
You're like,
what are you doing?
Somebody who was right there.
So I'm like,
she said,
I don't know.
Yeah,
that's right.
You were sitting at my table and you didn't tell me about it.
And I'm like,
why is he standing up?
I have a question show.
Sam's Sam's nine shows so much fun.
He goes,
his only regret with that.
I should have closed with it.
I didn't realize how much it would kill like two thirds of the way.
Another show.
Yeah.
It's tough to beat Rodney Roddy.
Defend Dana d Armand honor as a young woman.
Cause I as the amazing racist stuff is your or your parents rolling over in
their grave now cause you have sex with black eyes.
She goes,
my parents are still alive and you still act that way.
There's no excuses.
Sam's like,
we'll know and defend her.
Honor.
Hilarious.
She know you're going to do this.
You know,
worked it out.
She didn't know where I was gonna say,
but she could joke wrong with you.
She's funny,
man.
I listened to her on Brian's podcast.
What does it now?
Triple squad.
Yeah,
just talking funny.
She's a funny kid.
She's funny.
She's a weird,
she is.
She has herself.
You know what I'm saying?
Like she's not pretending to be anything other than that.
That's be too slutty.
And I'm like,
you're putting on an act here.
You're right.
Yeah.
Your lunch and you're thinking about warm Cox and your ass at lunch.
Get some girls like the crusts are cut off of the sandwich that you're,
you're taking a picture of some girls like it though.
They really do like words on,
there are some girls that are Nymphos,
but I know what you're saying.
Yeah.
She talks about that too.
Like she had the,
one of the things that she had on Twitter was a p.
People ask me the strangest thing I've ever had in my aunts,
my ass answer cat toys.
What's that?
I don't want to touch you or do you pick your hot?
Yeah,
that's not good.
I'm dying.
Maybe you're becoming a firestarter.
Wouldn't it be awesome food poisoning,
Sun,
you know,
that's why I need my barracuda.
The sick fish.
Why?
Because I had linguine and clams and fucking Chicago.
You gotta pee again.
Powerful.
Should for your bladder.
You and my goal boards get together again.
See who's got the stronger bladder episode?
Dehydrated from puking.
I haven't gotten the bathroom and I've had like a whole thing at PDL light,
a whole power,
Jamba juice,
the whole thing.
A C two o the pedialyte is the real shit.
That shit's good.
It's like Gatorade mix it.
It's really strong.
You know,
electrolyte replacement.
They use it for babies and just drink this whole thing.
Yeah,
you can drink the whole thing probably says though what the servings are.
I mean I don't think it's dangerous.
You should drink water with it as well though.
It's just an electrolyte replacement.
A lot of fighters drink that stuff right after they get off stage.
They,
a lot of them like to mix it like Dana drinks and stuff.
He mixes it water and that stuff.
So it's not too strong.
It says not to mix it on it.
So not to mix it really well.
I don't think he's doing it for babies for himself.
He's doing it for himself and I don't think he's doing it to like,
you know,
for health purposes.
I think it just doesn't like the taste wants too strong.
You're going to be okay.
No,
no.
I'm gonna die.
I feel like I'm ready.
Die.
Well,
good news is,
you know,
got a nice new car.
So at least you'll be feeling good as you're driving home.
The good car feeling.
We'll sort of partially mitigate [inaudible].
I feel sick just driving around.
Yeah,
I'm trying to talk.
Ours should fear into eventually getting a nice quality.
You feel sick because her car was invented by Adolf Hitler.
Unknown luck.
He made it.
He made it for,
there was no relation to that anymore.
I don't care at all.
I know is death squad made it for the Reich.
Whoa.
Don't confuse it too.
Don't even say that word.
What his death squad made it for the right answer,
but that's why I didn't make it.
It was for the people of Germany.
It wasn't for the right people going to think that you're some sort of a racist.
They'll know.
He's joking,
I think,
but some people will to do,
some people get confused.
Some people don't.
A lot of people don't know you're confused.
Um,
so you feel sick.
I got the meat sweats for the first time in Philadelphia.
What does that mean?
Uh,
when you just wake up,
I'll sweat.
There's just pouring sweat.
I feel like right now.
Have you never had it?
You've never had that meat sweats.
That's what they told me that what is in the radio the next morning?
Are you thinking about,
I'm always thinking about cock.
So it's not that,
that's what gives you the needs where it's,
can you imagine if it was just a cock thing?
It's like I get to tell why you sweating around us.
You're thinking about cock.
Can you imagine if like,
if like gay men had logo of Turkey test,
her on the forehead will pop up when you're thinking about man,
like Pinocchio was the sweating thing.
Maybe instead of a Turkey testers just sweat.
They're like when they figured about managers starts pouring sweat and everybody
knows what the fuck man.
That's why a lot of like weird gay shit goes down when guys are like playing
basketball cause everybody's sweating and you don't,
you can't detect.
This dude has got a boner and he's covering you from behind and he's really just
wants to fuck game.
Wow.
You feeling
when you're like,
oh it's a spider sense.
I think she's bring this,
bring this pitcher home when we think this is a fun podcast to do.
Very Fun.
I just fucking around always same shit we wouldn't be doing anywhere.
Yeah,
exactly.
Except that it becomes someone another a show Wednesday cobb's San Francisco,
ladies and gentlemen,
ours.
Your fears in his prime right now,
he's slaying them out there.
I've been working with her.
I would not,
I would not steer you wrong.
Go down there and check it out.
There's someone right fucking time.
No it wasn't.
It's a little worst thing to do.
Tell someone to go see someone who is not.
I do remember that when you use the lungs as a store and they're like an outlet
store,
it'd be like,
and they get the crowd be on your side,
you know?
And you'd be like,
guys,
listen,
I'm not going to lie to you.
There's a lot of shitty comics here,
but this next comic is not one of them.
Okay.
Later on I already seen a lot.
There's going to be some,
but this guy is not one of them.
He's good.
And it makes people trust you more like yeah,
it's hard when you have to bring,
when you're doing the thing at the store where you tag team and you're going up
the next guy.
If you have to bring up someone to socks,
hey guys,
well sit down cause there's a log of what you feel bad.
You know this is like,
especially those weird nine 30 spots.
We like,
what the fuck you get there?
You're like,
how'd that guy get in?
That's talk to get prime spots.
They're all nervous as shit going up.
Tough life.
Tough life was shit comic.
But are his fears not a shit comic?
He's fucking fabulous.
And you will go see him.
It was Wednesday and then this weekend sacrament.
I'm all over the country.
You guys go to already the great.com and see all my tour dates,
Bang everywhere and we will find out tomorrow whether or not we're doing a show
Wednesday night.
You like,
there's no way Joe,
you're the one scheduled.
You're not that crazy.
Yes.
There's the one scheduled.
No,
we don't necessarily have a long schedule.
I mean on the ice house schedule.
Yeah there is.
Maybe.
But we are definitely in the main room Friday at 10:30 PM
yeah.
So suck that into that.
Sucked that and that's me.
I'm in town.
So Friday 10 30 does it at the Oh great man.
I did an hour and seven minutes early night barbecued and I rescued some stuff
that I'd never done before.
It pulled it out like that.
I forgotten about turning a joke,
returning a joke,
turning,
turning a joke.
Tonya fruit.
It's like using it,
using it in a different context some other way.
It's not that.
It's some stuff that I never did before that I had written down into.
So it wasn't,
I had to start from zero.
I had already written some stuff that I was dabbling with that I didn't record.
So a it out of an hour and seven minutes.
There's a lot of fuckery too.
A lot of crowd play and a lot of fun.
So it's probably,
I think I'm probably around a half an hour in new stuff.
Real solid new stuff.
Not that I can put it on an album or anything yet,
but stuff that I really like where it's going.
It was good enough for a crop.
Yeah.
Well it's going somewhere.
It's going somewhere.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
the,
the is not going to be released until it looks like September 1st is when the
new website is going to be done.
It's new website is building a new website.
DOPA malicious.
Ridiculous.
Yeah,
it's good.
It's of,
we also got to build the infrastructure to handle all the paperwork and all the
bullshit for the traffic.
Cause I'm gonna sell the special online.
Oh yeah.
Best Special I've ever done for sure.
No,
no doubt about it and hands down the first person that ever did.
I watched it.
The first thing that I've ever did where I,
I I know it was like a real show.
It wasn't like I was just filming anything and I think a big part of that is
this podcast.
That's cool.
I was in the middle of it.
I even said that.
I'm like,
I thought I was going to be nervous.
I go,
this is like a regular show for me.
This is,
it's weird,
but then I realized everything.
I'm filming everything now.
It's like I'm doing these crazy podcasts so many hours a week.
Then I don't even get a little bit nervous about filming filming.
Dot.
It's not like,
well,
I got to get this.
I got to nail it down.
I felt like I did.
I did all the work I do.
I work that whole month.
I worked really hard prior crowd of fans than just comedy people and I was a
high priest like that.
It's like they're with you on,
you can't go to a place.
Yeah,
it was good.
But like,
we're not going to go there with you.
It was 100%.
And I appreciate the fuck out of it.
And,
uh,
I,
you know,
I say it all the time,
but it's because I mean it all the time.
I don't take any of this for granted.
We,
none of us do.
Brian doesn't,
uh,
I know already Joey doesn't have a whole different world from his podcast.
Yeah.
Joey called me up to date and told me he sold 390 tickets on like a Tuesday in
San Jose.
If you don't know,
it's just unhurtable broke it on a Tuesday for that.
You wouldn't do that.
No,
I probably sell 300 or something or two 50 or Tuesday.
Maybe.
I would have,
maybe I would have to like go on radio stations and really promote the shit out
of it and make a big deal out of it.
Between Twitter and a,
this podcast,
everything has sort of changed.
And like,
we,
we love the fact that you guys are enjoying it.
And when we feel a hundred percent dedicated and,
uh,
we feel responsible and we feel like,
um,
you know,
we have,
uh,
we have a responsibility to keep this thing going.
And if you guys want to pick up on all of us,
then all you have to do is take mushrooms July 21st 22nd or 23rd for shrimp
fest,
2012.
If you do,
I guarantee you you'll understand things we talk about on this podcast a little
bit differently.
People be like,
Oh yeah,
I'm okay.
Maybe.
Okay.
That's it for this week.
Next week.
Thank you everybody who enjoyed the John Anthony West podcast,
very controversial podcast,
and I want to try to get him on in the future with an egyptologist and I'm
willing to pay to fly guys out and put them up in hotel rooms because it
generated so much interest if he's related to each other.
Yeah.
There's a dude on my message board.
I'm gonna see if we could possibly this out.
I need moderate.
He,
well,
yeah,
I would sort of like let them figure out like,
you know,
there's,
there's uh,
there's a big debate about a couple of different specific subjects that have to
do with ancient Egypt.
But either way,
thanks to John Anthony West,
it was an awesome podcast.
Thanks to everybody who tuned into the show and all these fucking weird things
that we're doing.
I don't know what we're doing.
We're just doing it.
It just happened.
And here it is.
Thanks to the fleshlight for sponsoring us.
Thanks to on@dotcomgotojoerogan.net and click on a link for the flashlight and
during the code name Brogan and save yourself 15% off the number one sex toy
ferment the protein powders coming soon.
It will be within probably two months.
It's difficult,
difficult to get hemp hearts.
We're thinking about buying our own fucking hemp farm in Canada.
You should already have that.
Yeah,
we can.
Uh,
you can't,
it's hard to get him apparently hemp hearts,
so you can only buy 50 pounds a day.
Yeah,
it's a highly in demand,
really excellent source of protein.
But this protein powder is really delicious.
It's got Maca in it,
raw cocoa,
and it's flavored with a Stevia sweetened with Stevia.
So it's really good for you.
I,
I've been really enjoying the fact that doesn't make me Fart.
It's a really,
it takes away your farts just doesn't crush me like a sum or some protein
powders crushing me.
He knows,
especially when you mix a banana in it.
Some of them are just ruthless.
Uh,
but uh,
that's coming out too.
And kettlebells as well.
I'm going to announce kettlebells and I have a podcast.
That's right.
You do Irish beer skeptic,
a skeptic thing.
It's on iTunes now and it's also a Ari.
The great.com is his website.
Go there and check them out and uh,
make sure you subscribe or you don't follow.
Follow him on Twitter.
I'll subscribe to them on Twitter.
That's ridiculous.
That's crazy what you just said.
Talking nonsense.
A R I.
S h.
A f.
F.
I.
R.
U dirty bitches.
All right,
thanks to [inaudible] dot com go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the Alpha Brain logo.
Enter in the code ne Brogue and save yourself 10% off any and all orders.
That is the end of the show.
We will see you Wednesday with the great bill burr will be joining us,
so until then,
go fuck yourselves,
okay.
Okay.